COMMITTEE AND THE PUBLIC
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT SURFERS
COMMITTEE MEETING OF THE YEAR-
DO THE CONTINUE STAY HOME ORDER
FOR PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE HEARING ROOM. IN
PERSON ROSS REQUIRING THAT MASS
BE WARNED THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WITH
HERE IN THE ROOM OR REMOTE
VIDEO CONFERENCE SITE. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A MASK WHICH PROVIDE
ONE TO YOU. BEFORE WE BEGIN I'M
GONNA TAKE A COUPLE OF MINUTES
TO GO THROUGH A FEW OPTIONS AND
PROTOCOLS FOR WITNESSES
PARTICIPATION IN TESTIMONY
TODAY FOR THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN OF THE STATE
CAPITOL WERE MEETING. WEEKLY
COMEDY A MINIMAL NUMBER OF
STAFF THE PUBLIC AND THE MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FOR THE
SPACING. IS ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTINCT PROTOCOLS FOR
THE PUBLIC TO ENTER INTO THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THIS ROOM. IF YOU MEMBER THIS
WAUSA TESTIFY ON A BILL. UNLESS
YOU TO COME THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THAT YOU
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. AFTER
DONE SPEAKING YOU CONNECTS THIS
ROOM A RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT
PLEASE. MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
OBSERVING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS. MOVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME WITNESSES
MAKE USE OF OUR REMOTE VIDEO
STATIONS. LOCATED ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE CAPITOL GROUNDS IN
THE ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX THE
STATE CAPITAL FOR THIS HEARING.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE AND ASK
QUESTIONS. IF WE HAVE ANY.
WE'LL ALSO BE USING A MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THAT
WITNESSES. CAN USED TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL. THE CALLER NUMBER
FOR THE HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ONCE AGAIN THAT'S
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FOUR THREE ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN THAT'S
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. THE FINEST PHONE NUMBER
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE NINE
YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR THE BILL BEGAN
PRESENTING THE BILL. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TOBE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. DEPENDING
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE A BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE LUMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE SUCH AS
MEETING YOUR TV. LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN OTHER SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE INTERRUPTION
AND SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
PROPOSITION ON A BILL YOUR MAIN
ON A LIVE LINE ONLY TO MUTE
YOURSELF INTO YOUR CALL BONTA
SPEAK. THE EVERYONE IS ALSO
WHERE THIS COMMITTEE ACCEPTS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION ORAL EXCUSE ME THIS A
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE ENCOURAGES
THOSE. WHO HAVE ANY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES TO USE THIS
OPTION. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US WE CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTING METHODS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE HEALTH. AND
WELFARE CONCERNS WE ALL FACE.
WITH THEM IN TESTIMONY FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IDENTIFIED BY
EACH OTHER'S OFFICE TO TWO
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT. AND TWO
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION. EACH OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES MAXIMUM TO SPEAK.
IF THERE ARE LESS THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES REGARDLESS OF
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THE
MAXIMUM THREE MINUTES STILL
APPLIES. AFTER PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE DONE EVERYONE
ELSE WILL BE PERMITTED TO SAY
THEIR NAME. ORGANIZATION IF ANY
IMPOSITION ON THE BILL. I'LL BE
ASKING THE PHONE OPERATOR TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BICKER WHEN
YOUR TIME IS UP. THE ASSEMBLY
IS EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEES AND
FOR PROCEEDINGS. IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. SO THAT EVERYONE IS
CLEAR. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS
HEARING IS PROHIBITED SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE. REMOVING A
MASK REFUSING TO PUT A BACKLOG
IF YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN PERSON
OR VIA REMOTE VIDEO STATION
ORLA CAPITOL GROUNDS. TALKING
ARE MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE.
SPEAKING LONGER THAN TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED DISCUSSIONS
OF MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
BILL BEING DISCUSSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AT THAT TIME AND
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS. IF
SOMEONE DISTRICT ARE HEARING
PROCESS I WOULD WRECK THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THAT CONTINUED
DISRUPTIONS MA RESULT IN
REMOVAL. FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HEARING. I ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF THE
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT. I'M A
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP I WOULD REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS
REMOVING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE HEARING INCLUDING ESCORTING
THE INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. IF THEY'RE PHYSICALLY
PRESENCE. THANK YOU IN ADVANCE
FOR YOUR COOPERATION. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WHEN HIS DELTA QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CALL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
COOPER PRESENT COOPER PRESENT
VOEPEL. VOEPEL HERE CALDERON.
CALDERON PRESENT CERVANTES
COOLEY COOLEY PRESIDENT DONALD
HERE O'DONNELL PRESIDENT OF C.
R. TO HEAR. ZERO TO HEAR.
MEMBER SINCE THE FIRST MAYES
FIRST HEARING OF THE SESSION
OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE RULES
WHICH WERE PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED
TO YOUR OFFICE BYE COMMITTEE
STAFF LEVEL MOTION A SECOND TO
DOT THE COMMITTEE RULES. THANK
YOU SOME REAL BOTTLE IT MOVED
UP THE COMMITTEE RULES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY A SECOND TO THE
MOTION. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOPER HI COOPER AYE
VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES COOLEY
RIGHT COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I SEE ARE TOO HIGH
THEY ARE TOO HIGH. THE SECTOR
SKEWS ME. THE RULES ARE ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WITH THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS ON CONSENT AB THREE
THIRTEEN A. B. FOUR FOUR FOUR
AND EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE IS
THERE ANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO WISHES TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SKINNER GOT A MOTION.
BY MISTER O'DONNELL SECOND BUT-
MISTER SEA ARTICLE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE
ONE THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND BE RIVER RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR A. B. FOR DEEP PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR AB SEVEN SIX ONE TO
PASS TO CONSENT CALENDAR
COOPER. HI COOPER I VOEPEL
PROPELLED BY CULLEN CALDERON
AYE CERVANTES COOLEY COOLEY AYE
O'DONNELL. DONALD I THEY ARE TO
HIGH THERE ARE TWO I. WE HAVE
SIX VOTES WILL PUT THAT ON CALL.
OKAY WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA
STARTING WITH. A. B. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN GRAY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
TWO THIRTY SEVEN- THIS
AFTERNOON THIS BILL MEMBERS
PROHIBITS PUBLIC EMPLOYEES FROM
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS RATHER FROM
TERMINATING THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE OF EMPLOYEES IN THE
DEPENDENTS DURING A STRIKE AND
GRANTS THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BOARD JURISDICTION TO
ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. I BECAME AWARE MEMBERS OF
THIS TACTIC DURING THE U. A. W.
STRIKE AGAINST GM. GM'S
DECISION TO CUT OFF HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR STRIKING WORKERS
WAS MET WITH NATIONAL OUTCRY.
INCLUDING FROM THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
GM QUICKLY REVERSED COURSE I
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO PREVENT SUCH
BEHAVIOR IN CALIFORNIA BUT
FOUND THAT FEDERAL LAW PREEMPTS
OUR ABILITY AS A STATE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE THIS KIND
OF PROTECTION. FOR WORKERS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. THAT'S
WRONG AND SHOULD CHANGE AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE ACTION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT WHAT WE CAN
DO MEMBERS CREATE THESE
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES. AND THAT IS
THE BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. ACTUALLY ASK FOR YOUR- I
VOTE I HAVE WITH ME SEVERAL
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY- IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL INCLUDING
MICHAEL BOND WITH APPS ME
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE AND
JENNA SO MALLEY GLIZZY GO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIRMAN- THAT
YOURSELF FOR THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAY
OVERSEE WITH WITNESSES SUPPORT
OUR FIRST WITNESS. IS MICHAEL
EVAN. ON THE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BOUGHT. THANK YOU I AM THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
ASK ME THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE.
REPRESENT SERVICE WORKERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE GENERATORS.
GROUNDSKEEPERS CAFETERIA
WORKERS AND MEDICAL ASSISTANT.
YOU THE STATE LEGISLATOR GAVE
UP THE RIGHT TO STRIKE. AND
WHEN WE THE WORKERS DESPITE TO
EXERCISE THAT RIGHT. WE DO SO
AFTER WINNING ALL OTHER OPTIONS.
BECAUSE WHEN WE GO ON STRIKE WE
SACRIFICE. WE LOSE OUR PACE. WE
MAKE THAT SACRIFICE AND HOPE WE
CAN IMPROVE OUR LIVES AND THAT
OF OUR FAMILY. HOWEVER THERE IS
NO JUSTIFICATION FOR USE THAT
MEDICINE FOLLOW LIFESAVING
TREATMENT AS A WEAPON AGAINST
EXERCISING THAT RIGHT. FOR US
WE EXPERIENCED A RECENT THREAT
AT UC SANTA CRUZ WHEN THEY
INFORMED US THAT IF WE WERE
MADE ON STORY THAT WE WILL LOSE
OUR FAMILY'S HEALTH COVERAGE.
THIS OCCURRED AFTER UC'S NEW
THAT A STRIKE LEADERS SON WHAT
THE BATTLING BRAIN CANCER. WE
FELT THAT HIM WOMEN GRADE FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL
WHICH HELPS CLARIFY THE
WEAPONIZATION OF HEALTH CARE IS
NOT PERMITTED OKAY THIS STATE.
WE. FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WITNESS
JANICE AMALIA BELIEVES. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MALLEY GLUTEAL AND I
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ACT KEPT
HER THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH MEMBERS OF
ASKED ME THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE
ALONG WITH MANY OF OUR
AFFILIATES IN CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCILS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
BELIEVE THAT WITH HOLDING AN
EMPLOYEES HEALTH CARE. WHILE ON
STRIKE IS APPALLING AND
UNLAWFUL ECHO THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS DEMONSTRATED
UNMISTAKABLY THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
MPACT EVERYONE THERE SHOULD
NEVER BE ANY INCENTIVE TO CHECK
PEOPLE FROM THEIR HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE BECAUSE THE
CONSEQUENCES TO THEM TO THEIR
FAMILIES. AND TO THE ENTIRE
POPULATION CAN BE. ALLOW
EMPLOYERS TO WEAPONIZE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE SIMPLY TO GAIN
AN ADVANTAGE IN LABOR
NEGOTIATIONS. IS NOT ONLY
INCREDIBLY UNFAIR BUT DANGEROUS
TO OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY. THE FACT
THAT THERE IS. EMPLOYEES AT AN
UNFAIR DISADVANTAGE AND EVEN
THE THREAT OF SUCH ACTION BY AN
EMPLOYER SPONSORS TO WEAPONIZE
HEALTH CARE AND THE RETENTION
OF BENEFIT. THIS UNFAIR SCARE
TACTIC IT SHOULD NEVER BE USED
TO DISSUADE AN EMPLOYEE FROM
THE EXERCISE OF THEIR RIGHTS
UNDER THE LAW. EMPLOYERS MUST
BE PROHIBITED FROM CONTINUING
TO BENEFIT FROM THAT THE
GREATEST BEHAVIOR. THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
SEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD. TO ENSURING THAT ALL
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS. CAN
STILL RECEIVE THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE DESPITE MAKING THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO GO ON
STRIKE. WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBRANE HARD LEADERSHIP ON
THIS. FIFTY ON THIS BILL TO
PROTECT OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NESTLE
HAVE WITNESSES SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ANYONE THIS IS A
HEARING ROOM. OKAY SAYING NONE
LITTLE WOODEN SAYS VIA THE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION. SEEING
NONE WILL WITNESSES SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR. THE
DOCUMENT YOU WISH TO COMMENT
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
MAY BE HIT ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OF COURSE TO GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MALIK BYNUM WITH NINE
BASIC WORKERS ASK ME THIRTY
NINE THIRTY. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS TO GO TO
NINE TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CERTAIN BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE TO SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TAYLOR
JACKSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANKS TO THE TIMELINE TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LAPAROTOMY
ACCU TEAMSTERS MACHINISTS NIGHT
UNTIL THE WORKERS ENGINEERS
EXACTLY CALIFORNIA HI A FEW KEY
LOCAL TWENTY ONE EACH YEAR WENT
TO COURT. THANK YOU. THANKS TO
THE TIMELINE THREE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CASH STANFORD
BEHALF OF THE AT THE ARE YOU.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- THANK
YOU. I COULD GO ON TO LINE
THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOUIS COSTA
WITH SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO THIRTY SEP THANK YOU.
RIGHT TO GO TO LINE THREE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME
JAY CROSSON LECTURE UC DAVIS
AND MEMBER IF YOU SEE AT EIGHT
UC AFT STRONGLY THE B. AND B.
FIFTY FIFTEEN YOU. THANKS TO
THE TWO ONE THREE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
BRAND THEIR AND READ OF SOCI
TRIP THE ORANGE COUNTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. MEXICO TIELINE
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GET YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTIE BELL
MY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE TO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS PARENTS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SELECT
FINEST NINE THREE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE BEEN
MISTER CHEN MEMBERS PUNGENCY ON
BEHALF OF U. A. W. VOCALS-
TWENTY FIVE AND FIFTY IT CAN IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS TO GO
TO LINE TWO EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SANDRA BROWN BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AT THE
PORT. TO GO TO LINE TWO SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JESSE HERNANDEZ AND I'M A
SENIOR COOK AT UC RIVERSIDE WE
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN WRITTEN BY ADAM
GREAT. THANKS TO GO TO LINE
THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ROB ROB SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF- I'VE GOT TO GET
THOSE CA CAN YOU GIVE ME- WE
CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO GO
ONLINE TO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TIME IS
CALLED QUEER WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO
THREE SEVEN. THANKS TO THE TO
LINE THREE OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON PAT
WHELAN HELD SOME OF MCAFEE HERE
ON BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA UNION
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL
INSTRUCTOR FOR THE BABY TO
THIRTY SEVEN THANKS. PIXIV ID
LINE TO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHICAGO
I'M A COULD. YEAH THEY MEDICAL
AND I SUPPORT IT. THE TO LINE
TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS DANIEL
SCHORR LIKE AND- ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNCIL. FEDERATION OF A
STRONG OF A TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
OUR NINE TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA TAURUS SHINY
TRANSPLANT FINANCIAL
COORDINATOR AT UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. WHAT MAKES A TO NINE
TO SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS WALKING CHAVEZ ON A
TECHNICAL WORKER UC DAVIS VICE
PRESIDENT OF UP THE CW A NINETY
ONE NINETEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
MEXICO TO LINE THREE SEVENTEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
WONDERWALL COVER CALLING THE
PORTS ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE TO SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BOTH NORMALLY NOW
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR INCOME
SUPPORT. THE NEXT TO GO TO TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS RICK CAL
PARL WITH COURAGE CALIFORNIA
AND TRUMP THE PART OF AB. CUTE.
THIRTY SEVEN. AT THE TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHER THAN Q. THANK YOU
NEXT REMOVED WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WITH NATIONAL
PARTNER WITNESSES A SUPPORT. SO
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION. YES
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT I ALSO
QUICKLY BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOBODY HERE I CAN GIVE TIME
NEED LIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO USE
THAT AS STATE I'M JOHN RUN IN
WITH YOU AFT. R. VICE PRESIDENT
OF VICE PRESIDENT LEGISLATION
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
SORE BACK TO WITNESSES
OPPOSITIONI HAVE BEEN IN THE
ROOM. AND HAVING THE SUPPORT SO
WE'RE GONNA WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. I DON'T BELIEVE THERE
ARE ANY. NESTLE UP WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. IF YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. SB
BETTER COMMITTEE KNOWN IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU. LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'LL
CAN WE GOT A FIRST AND SECOND-
TERRY BACK MISTER RAY WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT ON YOUR BILL. LORSCH
CHAIRS NO I ONLY BRING YOU GOOD
BILLS WITH NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I FORGOT A MOTION BY MISTER
COOLEY SECOND BY MR O'DONNELL
IN THE BILL- SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER EYES VOEPEL
NOT. VOEPEL NOT VOTING CALDERON
CALDERON AYE. CERVANTES COOLEY-
COOLEY I O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
EYES THEY ARE TO. YOU CAN ROLL
REMAIN OPEN ON THAT. NEXT WE'LL
PROCEED TO- AB NUMBER FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT AS A MEMBER REYES
MEMBERS OF THE BILL WHEN YOU'RE
READY I THANK MR REX BLAMES
CHAIR MEMBERS.
MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB FOR THIRTY EIGHT AND
EQUITY MEASURE WHICH
STANDARDIZES THE LAYOFF PROCESS
THAT EXTENDS HEARING RIGHTS.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SO THAT
THE SAME PROTOCOLS EXIST FOR
ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. CURRENTLY
ONLY CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE
PINK SLIP NOTICE OF JOB
PROTECTION BY MARCH FIFTEENTH
IF THEY DON'T RECEIVE THEIR
PINK SLIP BY MARCH FIFTEENTH
THEIR JOB IS PROTECTED. FOR THE
NEXT SCHOOL YEAR. PLUS FIVE
EMPLOYERS ON THE OTHER HAND CAN
BE LET GO AT ANY POINT IN THE
SCHOOL YEAR WITH JUST A SIXTY
DAY NOTICE. MOREOVER
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE
TO CONTEST OF THEIR LAYOFFS VIA
HEARING PROCESS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT AFFORDED THIS
RIGHT. AB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
INSURERS ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
REGARDLESS OF THE JOB TITLE ARE
GRANTED THE SAME LAYOFF NOTICE
AND WORKER PROTECTIONS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS LIBBY SANCHEZ. GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ADVOCATE WITH THAT'S
THE ARGUE. AT THE LOWER EAST
AROUND FLORIDA'S LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATES WITH CSEA CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. A MEMBER YOU. PUT
PLEASE PROCEED. MY NAME IS
DORIS STRAND FLORIST I
REPRESENT YEAH YEAH WITH THE
RESPONSE THERE'S BEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THREE EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
THREE EXACTLY IT'S ABOUT
FAIRNESS IN ABOUT. DOING THE
RIGHT THING. WE PROVIDE ALL
OVER FOR YOU WITH THE WAY OFF
NOTICE AND HEARING. DEVELOPER
ONE SET GOALS FOR THE LOWEST
RETURN AND STAFF THE HIGH RATES
ARE. BUT YOU. WITH THEIR BUDGET
ON THE BACKS OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEE. THE LAW IS STRUCTURED
A WAY THAT ALLOW THEM TO DO
THIS BUT IT IS HI TO CHANGE
THAT. AND UNJUST LAW. BY THE
POLICE ARE HERE 80% WOMEN THERE
ARE MOST DIVERSE WORKFORCE IN
MANY ELEVEN THE COMMUTER WHERE
THEY WORK. BY THE BOYS ARE TO
WORK FOR ON THE FRONT LINE OF
THE. I'VE HEARD CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES REFERRED TO WITH
HEROES YET TWO THOUSAND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND LAID
OFF DURING THE PANDEMIC EVEN
THOUGH THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT
CUT SCHOOL FUNDING AND HELP
DISTRICT BUDGETS ARE WHAT. THE
STATE BUDGET EVEN HAVE IN LIKE
TELLING DISTRICTS NOW TO LAY
OFF LAST BY THE POLICE BUT THEY
DID. IT MIGHT CARE EDUCATOR WHO
WORKS SPECIAL STUDENTS THEY
LAID OFF I SPECIAL DURING.
LEARNING AND THEY LAY OFF
HEALTH CARE EIGHT DURING A
HEALTH CARE P. AND. FIVE
EMPLOYEES ARE WAY OFF OR
FEATURE AN ADMIN OF THE PROTECT
IT. EVERY TIME THERE'S AN
DOWNTURN CLASSIFIED INFO.
ALREADY TO WELL WHAT'S GOING
WORK. HEY THE- IT'S NOT GAP
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR TREATMENT
FOR ASKING THE STATE TREATMENT
IT'S- YEAH OF PROVIDING ARE NOT
THE MARCH FIFTEEN LEYVA NOTICE.
MY OFFICE. IS SIGNIFICANT AND
PERHAPS MORE SO FOR LOWER WAGE
EMPLOYEES THEIR FAMILIES SUFFER
REGARDLESS OF THEIR EDUCATIONAL
LEVEL. REYES CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS BILL UP FIND A
PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEES WE
AMENDED IT TO CLARIFY THAT IT
DOES NOT. ARE OPEN TO AMENDING
THE BILL TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES. BUT
WE'RE NOT OPEN TO ANYTHING LESS
THAN PARITY AB FOUR THREE EIGHT
IT'S ABOUT FAIRNESS AND TEXTING
AND I'M JUST LAW. WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS
RELEASED SANCHEZ. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS LIBBY
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF AT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THIS
BILL ISN'T JUST ABOUT READY FOR
THE SAKE OF THE FINANCING OR
EQUITY IT'S ABOUT PARITY TO
RECTIFY ONE COMPONENT OF THE
DRAMATIC DISPARITY. UNFAIR AND
IMBALANCED DYNAMIC BETWEEN OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THE LOWEST
WAGE WORKERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYERS. AND DEMOCRAT OUTTHE
HEROES AMONG US NONE OF WHOM
WERE CAPE BUT MANY OF WHOM WERE
LUNCH LADY HER NOT BUT DRIVER
UNIFORMS OR SPECIAL ED AIDE
LANYARDS THESE ARE CLASSIFIED
WORKERS WHO DIDN'T MISS A BEAT
TO THE DETRIMENT OF THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND SAFETY TO ENSURE
THAT KIDS WHO RELY ON FREE AND
REDUCED BREAKFAST AND LUNCH FOR
THEIR VERY SURVIVAL. THAT EACH
AND EVERY DAY OF THE PARENTS I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY EMAIL
NOTICE THAT I RECEIVED OVER THE
PAST THIRTEEN MONTHS FROM FACT
TO BE UNIFIED NOTIFYING THE OF
ANOTHER INCIDENT OF COALBED
AMONG CLASSIFIED FOOD SERVICE
YEAH BUT I CAN'T HELP YOU EVEN
THOUGH THERE WERE TOO MANY OF
THOSE NOTICES THE COUNT. THOSE
HEROES AMONG US KEPT ON DOING
THEIR JOB AND NOT JUST FOR
CLASSIFIED STAFF DO THE VERY
GLUE THAT KEEPS OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM TOGETHER ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES LIKE THESE BUT IT IS ALSO
IN TIMES LIKE THESE THEIR LACK
OF JOB SECURITY AND ANY CALL
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW THE
COMFORTABLE WEARING. OPPOSITION
WOULD HAVE YOU BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDING CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
TIMELY AND CONSTRUCTIVE NOTICE
WOULD CREATE CHAOS FOR SCHOOLS
AND FAMILIES YES NO BUT SIMILAR
CHAOS ENSUES WHEN FOLLOWING
THESE PROTOCOLS FOR
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES AND
ADMINISTRATORS THE REAL CHAOS
IN THE LIVES OF CLASSIFIED
STAFF- AGAIN AS THE LOWEST WAGE
WORKERS IN THE SYSTEM ARE
EXPECTED TO MANAGE WITH SIXTY
DAYS NOTICE. AT ANY TIME DURING
THE YEAR AND THAT'S ONLY WHEN
THEY'RE ENTITLED THANK YOU THE
NOTICE A GRANDER EXISTING. LAWS
THEY ARE NOT ALWAYS. THE
OPPOSITION WITHOUT HELP YOU THE
THIS WILL LEAD TO INCREASE
COSTS AT THE- WITH CARING
APPEALS OF THE WHITE. WHAT'S IN
THE BOX YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
ONCE AGAIN THAT'S NOW THE
DYNAMIC DAY. AFFECTED AND IN.
STAFF AND MORE IMPORTANT.
EXPENDITURES WOULD BE WITHIN
THEIR CONTROL AS THEY WERE CAN
TO HAVE IN THEIR- ABOUT WHETHER
IT ANY OF PLAYOFF NOTICES. THAT
WOULD GIVE RISE TO THESE
HEARINGS AND APPEALS. WON'T
CREATE CHAOS IT WON'T WREAK
HAVOC. BUT IT WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE TO THE LIVES OF
CLASSIFIED WORKERS BY ENSURING
THAT THEY NO LONGER HAVE TO
WORRY FROM ONE MOMENT TO THE
NEXT. WHETHER AND WHEN A LAYOFF
NOTICE MIGHT COME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MOVIE.
WITNESSES SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THANK YOU KEVIN-
MY NAME IS JOHN RUN IT I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT LEGISLATION FOR
THE UC AFT AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NASA MOVED WITNESSES SUPPORT
VIA REMOTE VIDEO STATION.
HEARING NONE MOVED WITNESSES
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. OPERATOR
DAVID DERMER WHO WISH TO
COMMENT SUPPORT TEAM A PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME TO GO
TO NINE TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WANT TO THANK THE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP THAT SORT OF STUFF
BROWN BOTH FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THREE EIGHT. MEXICO
CLIMBED TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MOVE ONTO LINE TO NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON THE
AFTER THE TEAMSTERS AND
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION COURT
THANK YOU. THE NEXT ONE TO GO
TO LINE THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL THIS IS
JENNIFER VALLEY WITH A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT. MEXICANA GO TO
LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORED THE BILL I AM PROUD
TO WORK. NEXT AVAILABLE TO LINE
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SORRY THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CALL QUERY WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR THREE EIGHT. MEXICAN TO GO
NINE THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OUR DOCTOR EMILY
WHITE BERG GLOBAL MOBILE NUMBER
FIVE COOPER CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATE FELL.
FOR THIRTY EIGHT. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DANIEL
CHERYL. UCSD IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FOUR THREE EIGHT
THANK YOU. HI. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT REMOVED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I'VE
GOT- TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
FIRST UP IS CINDY FOR OZZY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CINDY
FREE I'M THE ASSOCIATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES IN THE SAN DIEGO
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M
ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS HUMAN
RESOURCE COUNCIL IN HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING ACCESS. OF THE
HUMAN RESOURCE ADMINISTRATOR MY
JOB IS TO ENSURE EMPLOYEES ARE
SUPPORTED AND PROTECTED WE
VALUE BOTH ARE CLASSIFIED AND
CERTIFICATED STAFF IN FACT
ABOUT THE COMMITMENT OF OUR
CLASSROOM PLOYS WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO OPEN OUR SCHOOLS
SAFE GOING TO PUT OUR STUDENTS
TO THE PANDEMIC THIS YEAR.
HOWEVER WE MUST OPPOSE EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS. EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT ATTEMPTING TO
ISOLATE ACROSS THIS BILL
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEE THE LAPTOP
SPECIFICALLY IT IS QUITE
DIFFERENT FROM CLASSIFIED
CERTIFICATE REDUCTION IS BASED
SOLELY ON SENIORITY AND
CREDENTIALING FIGURING BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE RECORD ON SENIORITY AND
CREDENTIALING OF FOLLOWED. THE
COST BUT PROCESS INCLUDES
BOOKING RIGHT THEY'RE
PRESCRIBING EDUCATION GOING
FURTHER NEGOTIATED SPOKE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ACOSTA IMPLICITLY
ARE FREQUENTLY CROSSES MANY JOB
CATEGORIES AND CLASSIFICATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE THE LAYOFF OF THE
DISTRICT OFFICE SECRETARY THREE
THEY MAY HAVE ALREADY WORKED AT
THE SCHOOL SITE SECRETARY. THEY
WOULD BUMP INTO THAT POSITION
DISPLACES SECRETARY WITH MORE
SENIORITY THAT SECRETARY NAY
THEIR OFFICE CLERK AND THEY
WOULD BUMP INTO THAT JOB.
CELESTINA CLERK MAY HAVE BEEN
AN INSTRUCTIONAL ASSISTANT AND
THEY WOULD BUMP THE LISTING OR
INSTRUCTIONAL FIT THAT MADE
THEM LOSE THEIR JOB. YOU CAN
SEE THE COMPLEXITY OF PREPARING
FOR CLASSIFIED LIKE ALL THAT
ALL BUT PUT IN PLACE- PAID OUT
OF THE DISTRICT GENERAL FUND
SUMMER SUPPORTED BY TARGETED
STATE FEDERAL FUNDS IF THERE
ANY CUTS TO THE PROGRAM SUCH AS
TITLE ONE OUR CHILD NUTRITION
ANGELA I NEED YOUR THE
CUTTHROAT OF THE CONTROL OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT YES UNDER
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE TO
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT WITH
RESOURCES FROM THE GENERAL FUND
WHICH WITH A. PROBLEM THAT MAY
EVEN NO LONGER EXISTS. PERSONAL
FOR SCHOOLS. ARE 90% OF OUR
GENERAL. DURING THE BREAK WE-
OF. EIGHT POLITICAL SUPPORT TO
MAKE ME CUTS TO SCHOOLS AROUND
OF OUR CONTROL. THE BILL
DISTRICTS OF. EXTRA DIFFERENT
DECISION IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
OUR STUDENTS ARE AND BATTLE THE
BUDGET. I A DISTRICT THAT WOULD
LIKE HEAVILY ON STATE BUT WHICH
WOULD BE DEFERRED. WITHIN THREE
MONTHS WE HAD TO PAY THAT AND
MAKE BUDGET CUTS KEEP THE-
FISCALLY SOLVENT. EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT WITH A PREVENTED A
TO MAKING A- LIKE. KEEP UP THE
FLOW. OF WHERE WE OPENING FROM
THE- THERE MANY. FACTORS WE ARE
DEALING WITH. THIS PAST YEAR'S
BEEN. DIFFICULT AND ALL OF OUR
STAFF IN MY H. HER OFFICE I
HAVE ALL CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
JUST KEEP UP WITH THE DEMANDS
OF THE PANDEMIC CONTAINING
SUBCONTRACTORS INCLUDE THE
TESTING ARRANGING VACCINATION.
ON TOP OF THEIR NORMAL DUTIES
THEY HAVE HAD LITTLE TIME OFF.
AS WE TRY TO PLAN FOR NEXT YEAR
OUR STUDENT COUNT IS EXPECT
UNEXPECTEDLY DOWN BY FOUR
HUNDRED STUDENTS. THE REDUCTION
IN OUR STUDENT POPULATION
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS THE
DISTRICT'S BUDGET. WITH SO MANY
UNKNOWNS WE DON'T BELIEVE THIS
IS THE TIME TO PLACE A NEW
MANDATE ON SCHOOL WORK AND ONE
THAT IS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
TO MEET. A MARCH FIFTEENTH
NOTICES THE BUMPING RIHT
OFFICE WILL PLACE MORE STRESS
ON EMPLOYEES NOT LESS. IT
WEIGHS HEAVILY ON ME TO DISCUSS
PEOPLE'S JOBS. AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY I HAVE TO ENSURE
OUR STUDENTS HAVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION WHILE MAINTAINING THE
P. SHERRY RESPONSIBILITIES OF A
DISTRICT. LEGISLATION THAT
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
VERY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO MAKE ALL OF
OUR DECISION. MORE DIFFICULT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT UP
IS CHRIS REES. ROOF THANK YOU
MUCH CHAIR- AND MEMBERS. THAT
PROVIDED. THANKS CHRIS FREE AND
I'M HERE BEHALF OF THE COP.
SCHOOL BOY. OF THE- INTO
OPPOSITION BEFORE. EIGHT A
GREAT RESPECT FOR THE- HOWEVER
MOST INTO PROPOSED ON THE BILL
BECAUSE IT STRUCK THE HEART OF
LOCAL INFORMED MAKING AND
RESTRICT THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARDS. TO MAKE TIMELY
AND NECESSARY BUT TO DATE BUT
IT'S HER DECISION. WE
APPRECIATE ISSUE THE BILL RIGHT
RAISES HOWEVER WILL GET UNCLEAR
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS AND THE PROBLEM IS
TRYING TO SOLVE. CURRENT LAW
FOR QUITE QUITE THAT BUT IF YOU
DIDN'T LET UP NO TO. PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS AND ARE PERMITTED
TO EXERCISE CONDITIONAL
PLACEMENT INTO OTHER COPPER
PIPE MISSION BASED PUNK
SENIORITY THAT YOU'VE HEARD.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A SHORT TERM
BUDGET SURPLUS THE REALITY IS
THAT THE STATE WILL BEGIN TO
EXPRESS THE EURO FOR YOUR
STRUCTURAL BUDGET DEFICIT. IN
THE PAST DURING BOTH THE .COM
RECESSION THE GREAT RECESSION
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE FORCED TO
OVER NOTED CONTRIBUTED THE
MARCH FIFTEENTH REQUIREMENTS.
IF ADOPTED THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN THE OVERNIGHT THING
OF CLASSIFIED STAFF. THIS WILL
EXACERBATE AND NOT NECESSARILY
INCLUDE THE DESTRUCTION AND
UNCERTAINTY THE MARCH FIFTEENTH
DEADLINE ALREADY CREEK WHICH
BECAUSE OF. FEAR AND
UNCERTAINTY IN TEACHERS AND
CREATE DOUBT AMONG STUDENTS M.
BLACKLY. LAUGHTER NEVER EVEN.
SCHOOL DISTRICT STRIVE TO AVOID
LAYING OFF STAFF HOWEVER CAN BE
AN OPTION OF LAST RESORT.
THAT'S OUR REGION BUT IF AND
MAKE UP THE VAST MAJORITY OF
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGET
AMOUNTING TO AS MUCH AS NINETY
PERCENT. BY ADDING CLASSIFIED
STAFF TO MARTY FIFTY
REQUIREMENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WILL NOW BE REQUIRED TO ACT
UPON NEARLY 90% OF ITS BUDGET.
FOR THREE MONTHS. BEFORE THE
STATE BUDGET IS ADOPTED. PRIOR
TO CAN'T GET A SCHOOL THAT FOR
ALL SPEAKING DIFFICULT.
DECLINING THE STATE'S LAW TERM
PROJECTED BUDGET OF. INCREASING
PENSION. AND OTHER COSTS IMPACT.
GIVEN NEED CERTAIN. WE NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO MAKE. OF THIS
SCALE TOWARD EMPLOYMENT
PROCESS. THEIR FOCUS REMAIN ON
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO BEST
SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF IN
A CONSTANTLY SHIFTING
ENVIRONMENT. FOR THESE REASONS
WE STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
REMOVED WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. ANY
WITNESSES IN HEARING ROOM.
SINGA WOULD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. DOES ANYONE OPPOSITION
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
OPERATOR. HE WAS TO COME IN
OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE OF
THEIR AT THIS TIME. BUT TO GO
TO LINE THREE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CRISTINA MARCELLA ON
BEHALF. OF THE NATION'S IN
OPPOSITION. TO GO TO LINE THREE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'LL I'LL AN I'LL BE HAPPY AT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
MOMENT. I'D LIKE TO GO TO LINE
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANDREA BALL AND A HALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION. IN
MEXICO TO LINE THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
MERRY GO BANG OF THE UC
ACADEMIC SENATE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION I HAD SOME PREPARED
REMARKS STORY SAY THEM NOW OR
LATER. NOW ALTHOUGH THE NORTH
MARKS YOU HAS YOUR NAME AND
POSITION- VERY GOOD PAYING
CHAIR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ACADEMIC SENATE.
THANK YOU. CONNECT TO THE TO
LINE THREE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE TWENTY
EIGHT ON THE OPEN. RIGHT MODE
UNTIL NINE THREE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICK NGLY
ON BEHALF OF K. ROCK OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY GOING BACK TO NINE THREE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE TWENTY AIRLINES OPEN-
RIGHT I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
NAY. THANK YOU FOR- THANK YOU
SO I MAY SPEAK MY TALKING
POINTS NOW NO JUST AT YOUR NAME
WHO YOU'RE WITHIN YOUR POSITION
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
MARIGNANE CHAIR AT THE UC
ACADEMIC SENATE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BACA REPRESENTATIVE
RIVERSIDE NINETY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
OPPOSITION. EXHIBITOR LINE
THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AT THE TIME THAT NO OTHER
THAN Q. OKAY THANK YOU OPERATOR
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE- SWIMMER REYES WAS LIKE
CLOSING YOUR BILL. S. THANK YOU
THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO SHARE
MISTER CHAIR HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH BUMPING RIGHTS IN FACT
CLASSIFIED EMPOYEES DO NOT
HAVE BUMPING RIGHTS ITS STATE
STATUTE LIKE TEACHERS DO
INSTEAD THEY NEGOTIATE THESE
RIGHTS IN LOCAL BARGAINING FOR
DISTRICTS HAVE A VOICE. FOR
DISTRICTS AGREE TO BUMPING
RIGHTS THE YET THEY UNDERSTAND
THEM AND THEY CURRENTLY USE
THEM ON THE LAY OFF PLUS PART
OF BOYS THIS BILL JUST REQUIRES
DISTRICTS TO SENT OUT LAYOFF
NOTICES AT THE SAME TIME
INSTEAD OF DOING IT THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
THERE'S NO MOTION YET SO
THEREFORE- MOTION A SECOND.
WITH A MOTION BY MISTER DONALD
SECOND BY MR BONTA IS- MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. EMISSION IS THE PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER. HI COOPER I VOEPEL HI
VOEPEL I CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
ICR TO. THIS BILL HAS SIX
VOTES. FOR THE BILL'S LOCAL
STILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS- NEXT WILL MOVE
TO EXCUSE ME AB TEN THIRTY ONE.
FEDERAL PULA. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE A. B.
TEN THIRTY ONE WILL HELP SIR
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
FIND EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
BY HELPING SURVIVORS ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FIND SAFE AND
PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. ACCORDING TO THE
STATE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS
AMONG. THE WORLD'S FASTEST
GROWING CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE
ESTIMATED TO BE ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTEEN BILLION A YEAR GLOBAL
INDUSTRY WITH MANY INDIVIDUALS
BEING FORCED INTO THE INDUSTRY
DUE TO PROPERTY. AND LACK OF
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. SORRY.
AS A RESULT MANY INDIVIDUALS
BECOME TRAPPED IN THE CYCLE OF
ABUSE INCLUDING PSYCHOLOGICAL
TRAUMA SHAME EMOTIONAL
ATTACHMENT OR PHYSICAL THREATS
TO THEMSELVES OR THEIR FAMILIES
WERE MANY TRAFFICKING
INDIVIDUALS IT IS DIFFICULT TO
CHANGE THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES MANY
DO NOT SEEK HELP DUE TO FEAR OR
DO NOT HAVE RESOURCES OR
SUPPORT NEEDED TO SEEK
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
MAY CHANGE OUR LIVES AND HELP
THEM FROM. FALLING BACK INTO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AB TEN
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE WILL
REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES TO GIVE
ADDITIONAL PREFERENCE TO
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN HIRING FOR INTERNSHIP. AND
STUDENT ASSISTANT PROGRAMS AB
TEN THIRTY ONE WILL HELP
SURVIVORS ON HUMAN OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT
AND HELP THEM FROM FALLING BACK
INTO THE LIFESTYLE. WITH ME
TODAY IS JOE GOMEZ DO WELL
GOMEZ CEO OF THE CHILDREN'S
HOME OF STOCKTON AND THE CHAIR
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE IS SUIT
ESTUDIANTE SCHULTZ WITH THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO WIN THIS IS
SUPPORT AND FIRST LOGOS IS
ESSENTIAL. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COOPER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING IS
REPRESENTATIVES AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY ONE. AND MY NAME IS TOO
SCHULTZ FIND A PUBLIC SERVANT
WHO IS PASSIONATELY SERVED MY
COMMUNITY FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
I AM A STAFF MEMBER OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WHERE I SERVE
AS THE PROGRAM MANAGER FOR OUR
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER. AS MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST NUMBER FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS IN THE NATION AT TWENTY
FIVE. AND WE ALL ARE SERVING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. WE
BRING TO BE TOGETHER MULTI
DISCIPLINARY GOVERNMENTAL AND
NONPROFIT PARTNERS UNDER ONE
ROOF TO BETTER SERVE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
SEXUAL ASSAULT STALKING. ELDER
ABUSE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I
MUST SAY THAT HOPE IS A DRIVING
FACTOR FOR SURVIVORS. HOPE FOR
A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE HOPE FOR
THE GRANTING OF PROTECTIVE
ORDERS HOPE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE TRAUMA. FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS HOPE FOR
FUTURE EMPLOYMENT OUTSIDE OF
THE LIFE. IS AT THE FOREFRONT
FOR MANY OF THEM. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS THAT I'VE WORKED WITH
HAVE ENTERED INTO THE WORLD OF
EXPLOITATION AS CHILDREN
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE. THEY ARE
THEN DISCARDED LIKE TRASH WHEN
THEY'RE LUCRATIVENESS AND
APPEAL DIMINISH BY THEIR MID TO
LATE TWENTIES. MANY DO NOT
POSSESS HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS AS
THEY WERE PREYED UPON WHEN THEY
WERE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
SURVIVORS POSSESS LIFE
EXPERIENCES IN THE UNDERBELLY
OF THE EXPLOITATION INDUSTRY
THAT MANY OF US CANNOT GRASP. A
SURVIVOR ONCE SAID TO ME I
APPRECIATE YOUR BACKPACK OF
FOOD AND TOILETRIES BUT WHAT I
REALLY NEED IS A JOB.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WILL
PROVIDE HOPE FOR SURVIVORS AND
THE REALIZATION THAT THEY TRULY
ARE VALUABLE. THEY WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REGAIN THE
POWER OF THE TRAJECTORY OF
THEIR LIVES. MANY OF THE
SURVIVORS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF ASSISTING HAVE
EXPRESSED THEY WAT TO PURSUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP OTHERS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS THE FIRST
STEP IN OPENING THE DOORS OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM WHICH WILL
BE A BENEFIT TO US ALL. IT IS
WITH A HOPE FILLED HEART THAT I
SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF AB TEN
THIRTY ONE AND I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU NEXT UP IS
WELL GOMEZ. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS YOU'RE WELCOME THAT
I AM THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE CHILDREN
STOCKTON AND SHARED WITH THEM
JOAQUIN COUNTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE I SPENT
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS ADVOCATING
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN MY CURRENT
CAPACITY AT BHS WE PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE FOR YOU
TWO HUNDRED FOSTER GIVE EACH
YEAR IN STOCK VENTURA. COUNTY
AND COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR AT RISK YOUTH
WILL HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE WHILE
EVERY FEEDING CRITICAL SERVICES
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT COULD BE
PREVENTION EDUCATION AND
TRANSITION AFTER CHARACTER
DEFECTS. APPROXIMATELY AND I
WOULD STILL BE CONSERVATIVELY
30% OF THE YOUTH AGES TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN THAT WITH THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS THAT HE TRAFFICKING
OR AT THE BAR AT THE RISK OF
THE WORD EACH OF THE DARK
WORLD. OUR HOPE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSES ON UNIQUE
NEEDS AND CHALLENGES THAT
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
FACE WHEN IT COMES TO
UNDERSTANDING THE COMPLEXITIES.
IN DARK WORLD OF TRAFFICKING
RECOVERING FROM THE TRAUMA
RESULT IN THEIR LIFE AND
EDUCATE THE TRANSITIONING TO IT
INDEPENDENT LIVING ARRANGEMENTS
FACT SHE FEATURE ACCORDING
PROVIDERS ONLY PAINTING LONG
TERM SUCCESS. ACCESS TO A
REASONABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
STANDARD OF LIVING WITH
OPPORTUNITY FOR ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT. PASSAGE OF AB TEN
THIRTY ONE WHAT GO A LONG WAY
IN ENSURING THAT PROVIDERS DO
NOT FALL BACK INTO TRAFFICKING
BECAUSE OF LACK OF EMPLOYMENT
OR INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR MANY TRAFFICKING KIRSTEN'S
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES WHETHER
A JOB OR SOME FORM OF. INCOME
GENERATED FROM AN INTERNSHIP. I
THEIR PRIMARY FOCUS THANK
IMMEDIATELY AFTER EXIT THE
TRUCK SITUATION ON. THE LONGER
TERM PROCESS. ACT TO EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COOPER I WE
CANNOT SECURITY THE- IT. FOR
THE FACE. AND LONG TERM
RECOVERY OF CONTRACT. THEREFORE
I URGE THE PATH OF A TEN
THIRTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MY FOLKS
RUN A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE NEXT
REMOVED. WITNESSES SUPPORT HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NONE WOULD WITNESSES- VIA
REMOTE VIDEO STATION SUPPORT.
JUST LIKE WE DON'T HVE ANY
REMOVED OVER THIS IS ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PUSH
COMMENTS SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE DALLAS
MORNING KILL. OKAY REMOVED
WITNESSES OPPOSITION- I DON'T
HAVE ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
HAVE ANY NO WITNESSES SO MOVED
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE RADIO STATION. SEEING NONE
WILL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR. IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT OPPOSITION IN A
PRESS ONE THERE AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR REVERIE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THEN CLOSER
COMMENTS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WELL HEY GOOD MOVE BY MR COOLEY
SEGMENTS CALDERON- MISTER WILL
PUT UP WE LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT ON YOUR BILL
I WOULD MISS CHAIRMAN- THANK
YOU MEMBERS- I JUST BOUGHT ONE
SAY SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CANNOT SEEK HELP ON
THE ROAD WHICH IS WHY IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THEY HAVE THESE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT NEEDED TO
SEEK AND SEEK EMPLOYMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU HEALTH SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE VOEPEL
AYE VOEPEL AYE CALDERON AYE
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES. COOLEY
HI COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL. C. R.
TO. THAT'S AVAILABLE TO HEAR
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT UP IS AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY- SOMEONE RIVAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ONTHIS BILL. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY PROTECTS FACULTY
BARGAINING RIGHTS BY ALLOWING
FACULTY WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN A
BARGAINING UNIT TO REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR UNION
REPRESENTATION EVEN IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MOVES
THOSE FACULTY POSITIONS TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE THIS MEASURE
WOULD ALSO PREVENT THE UC FROM
CREATING NEW FACULTY JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE ACADEMIC
SENATE THAT ARE VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL TO EXISTING
CLASSIFICATIONS CURRENTLY
REPRESENTED BY THE UNION. THREE
YEARS AGO THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT REQUESTED THAT THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS MOVE SIX PART
TIME NON SENATE FACULTY JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS FOR LECTURES
INTO THE ACADEMIC SENATE THE
SIX PART TIME POSITIONS WERE
ACTIVELY COVERED BY A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
PRIOR TO THE MOVE BUT LOST
THEIR UNION REPRESENTATION WHEN
MOVED TO THE ACADEMIC SENATE.
THIS DECISION WAS CHALLENGED BY
THE LABOR UNION THAT
REPRESENTED THE PART TIME
POSITIONS HOWEVER THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
DECIDED THAT THOSE JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS COULD NO LONGER
BE UNION REPRESENTED POSITIONS
BECAUSE OF RULES UNDER THE
HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS ACT THOUGH THE
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE VACANT AT
THE TIME THE UC DECIDED TO MOVE
THEM IT SETS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT THAT COULD RESULT IN
WORKERS LOSING THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATION. FOR EXAMPLE THE
UC COULD SEEK TO ELIMINATE AN
ENTIRE BARGAINING UNIT BY
MOVING ALL OF ITS CONSTITUENT
FACULTY JOB TITLES TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY PRESERVES EMPLOYEES
RIGHTS BY ENSURING THEY KEEP
THEIR UNION REPRESENTATION.
TODAY I HAVE. WITH ME TO
SUPPORT THE BILL JOHN RENDON UC
AFT VICE PRESIDENT FOR
LEGISLATION. AND MANUELA
BOUCHER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THANK YOU AND
FIRST UP IS- JOHN LONDON. THANK
YOU TRIMMING COOPER AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW ME TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY. MY NAME IS JOHN LENNON I
TEACH ANCIENT GREEK AND LATIN
FOR A LIVING I'M A LECTURER AT
UC DAVIS WHERE I'M PROUD OF ONE
EITHER UNIVERSITY WHY TEACHING
AWARD. I AM ALSO THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATION FOR
YOU SEE F. T. WE ARE THE UNION
THAT REPRESENTS LECTURES AND
LIBRARIES ACROSS THE UC. THREE
YEARS AGO THE UNIVERSITY MOVES
SIX JOB TITLES THAT WERE
REPRESENTED BY THE U. C. F. T.
INTO THE SENATE. AND
EFFECTIVELY STRIPPED THOSE
POSITIONS HAVE UNION
REPRESENTATION. MERELY BY
MOVING THEIR JOB TITLES INTO
THE SENATE. ALL THIS BILL DOES
IS FIX A FLAW IN HERE IS
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY TO ENGAGE IN UNION
BUSTING TACTICS. THAT'S IT.
WORKERS THAT HAVE A UNION
SHOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
UNION IF YOU SEE MOVES THEIR
POSITION INTO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THE UC ARGUMENTS
AGAINST THE BILL ARE EITHER
MISLEADING OR UNTRUE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE NOTION THAT SENATE
NON SENATE MEMBERS CANNOT EXIST
IN THE SAME UNIT IS FLAWED AND
UNFOUNDED. THERE IS NO REASON
THAT SOME SUBSECTION THE SENATE
SHOULD NOT BE UNIONIZED MANY
INSTITUTIONS HAVE DIFFERENT OR
BIFURCATE TARGETING TARGETING
IT'S AN THEM. ALSO JUST BECAUSE
THE SENATE MEMBERS CONFORMING
TO UNION UNDER EXISTING LAW.
DOES NOT MEAN IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THE UC TO UNILATERALLY
ELIMINATE UNION REPRESENTATION
FOR WORKERS ALREADY IN A UNION.
LASTLY THE BILL HAS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO LIMIT THE UC'S
ABILITY TO MOVE EXISTING
POSITIONS INTO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY SIMPLY
SIX TO ALLOW REPRESENTED JOB
TITLES THERE MOVED TO THE
SENATE TO RETAIN THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATION. I URGE A YES
VOTE ON AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THANK
YOU O MUCH THANK YOU AND
THAT'S WERE FROM WHEN MANUELA
COMMITTEE CANTINA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NOT ALLOWED TO SAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO BE HERE BECAUSE BALK
AT THE THOUGHT. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SIMPLY IN CONCERN ABOUT
FACULTY MEMBERS AT THE UC
RETAINER UNION REPRESENTATION.
REGARDLESS OF ANY UNILATERAL
ACTION TAKEN BY THE UNIVERSITY.
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY'S
HISTORY UNIONS HAVE BEEN
PIVOTAL TO ENSURE SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS FOR EMPLOYEES AND
CONDUCTED BY ALLIED WITH
MANAGEMENT. I NEED THE TUITION
WHICH LEADS TO AN EMPLOYEE'S
LOTS OF UNION REPRESENTATION
ARE BARGAINING POWER REALLY
IMPACTS THE MEMBERS WELL BEING
AND IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY THE ISSUER
SIMPLE FACULTY MEMBERS WHO HAVE
NO INPUT OVER THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE SHOULD NOT
LOSE THEIR UNION MEMBERSHIP IN
A POSITION FOR. VOTED FOR AN
ELECTED TO BE MEMBERS OF THE
ONLY BASED ON THE OPINIONS OF
THE FLEET. EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
DOES NOT IMPACT THE YOU CAN
ABILITY TO ELECT THE MEMBERSHIP
OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE BUT
MERELY ENSURE THAT ANY
CLASSIFICATION MOVED INTO THE
SENATE WILL RETAIN THEIR
PREVIOUS UNION REPRESENTATION.
THUS ENSURING THAT THE FACULTY
MEMBERS REMAIN COVERED BY THEIR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND UNDER THE PROTECTION OF
THEIR UNION. WE THANK
ASSEMBLYWOMAN REEBOK FOR
LEADERSHIP AND- JERRY AFTER
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MONEY FORCE
RON AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE
WITNESSES SUPPORT. SO MOVED TO
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THINGS MOVED WITH THIS IS
SUPPORT ON THE- VIDEO STATE. I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY WILL
MOVE TO WITNESSES SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR. IF YOU
LIKE TO COME IN SUPPORT IN THE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PURSUE THE TO LINE THREE
OH FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTOS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. BACK TO
THE CLIENT TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL YOUNG
THE NAPA CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS BY THE COSPONSORED
THE BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE TIME THREE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GARCIA
MOLECULAR UC DAVIS AND A MEMBER
OF THE C. A. S. T. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN FIFTY. I WANT TO LINE
THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TIM BERLINSKI LECTURE AT UC
DAVIS A MEMBER HE SAID T. AS
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. LINE THREE OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH ONLINE TO EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DANIEL CHERYL
LIBRARIAN AT UCLA UC AFT MEMBER
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOING ON THE LINE TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PICTURE MEMBERS NOT BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS TO
THE TIMELINE TO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN REMEMBER
MY NAME IS MADDIE AFTER THE
THREE YEARS WITHOUT LOCAL
THIRTY CA NINETY NINE REPORTER.
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN FIFTY.
EXADATA NINE THREE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROGER I'M A
LECTURER AT UC DAVIS AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. LET THE
DEADLINE TO SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WAS JUST WALKING
CHAVEZ I'M A TECHNICAL WORKER
UC DAVIS WITHOUT THE CW A
NINETY ONE NINETEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN QUICKLY.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE THREE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
LOCAL LAW. BOB DAVIS I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. BLACK TO THE
TWO ONE THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M SEAN
MCDONNELL I AM A LECTURER UC
DAVIS CALLING STRIKES A CHORD
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU.
THAT COULD LINE THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
ON TO NINE THREE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWO NINE THREE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M GONNA BE
ON BEHALF OF YOUR W. TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT AND INSTRUCT
THE COURT AND. EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FIFTY. NINE THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JOHN HANNER- PRESIDENT YOU SEE
A FEW LOCAL SIX THREE SIX
COVERING SEAMER CERTAINLY
SUPPORT AB. ONE FIVE FIVE ZERO.
THANKS TO THE TO LINE THREE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE THIRTY TWO LINES OPEN
PLEASE FROM YOUR PHONE. THE TO
LINE THREE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I'M CATHERINE AND
LECTURE AT UC IRVINE AND MEMBER
OF THE C. A. S. T. AND I'M IN
TRONG THE COURT AB. FIFTEEN
FIFTY. AT THE TIME THERE'S NO
OTHER THAN Q. THANK YOU NEXT
REMOVED WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN FIFTY. AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY WOULDN'T
WE DEPARTMENT SOME SORRY FIRST
UP IS MICHAEL BEDARD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL THE DART ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. YOU STILL PAY
RESPECT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY THE BILL
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. WHICH IS A
CRITICAL PART IN THE SHORT
GOVERNANCE MODEL FOR MANAGEMENT
AND ADMINISTRATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY. THE BILL AS ALSO
UNNECESSARY SENATE MEMBERS CAN
ALREADY UNIONIZED IN FACT THE
SANTA CRUZ FACULTY ASSOCIATION
HAS REPRESENTED MEMBERS OF THE
UC SANTA CRUZ ACADEMIC SENATE
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS. YOU
SEE THE PROUD UNION EMPLOYER
AND DOES NOT ENGAGE IN UNION
BUSTING TACTICS. BUT SENATE
FACULTY AND NON SENATE FACULTY
HAVE DIFFERENT INTERESTS AND
VERY DIFFERENT ROLES WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY. THAT IS WHY THE
ONLY APPROPRIATE BARGAINING
UNITS FOR SENATE MEMBERS. IS
ONE WHERE OTHER SENATE MEMBERS
ARE IN ONLY SENATE MEMBERS.
THIS BILL FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES
THAT. IF YOU'LL PAY AGAIN IS
NOT OPPOSED TO AN ORGANIZED TO
REPRESENT ACADEMIC SENATE. WE
ARE OPPOSED TO BARGAINING UNITS
THAT BLAND BUT DIFFERENT
FUNCTION THAN INTEREST THE
SENATE AND NON SENATE MEMBERS.
THE CURRENT LAW IS SUFFICIENT
TO GRANT SENATE MEMBERS
BARGAINING RIGHTS AND AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY UNNECESSARY
CHANGES THAT. IN A WAY THAT IS
DETRIMENTAL TO THE VALUE ADDED
TO THE UNIVERSITY BY THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. AND UNDERMINES
THE VALUE OF UC'S SHORT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. I BELIEVE
ON THE PHONE ALSO IS MERRY GOV
AND THE CHAIR OF THE UC
ACADEMIC SENATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT UP IS MARIE
WALDRON. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS MERRY LEVINE
AND I'VE BEEN A PROFESSOR OF
PSYCHOLOGY AT UC RIVERSIDE FOR
CLOSE TO THIRTY YEARS I AM THE
CURRENT CHAIR OF THE UC
ACADEMIC SENATE. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE TO ASK YOU
TO OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN FIFTY. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY REQUIRED SIX NEW
MEMBERS OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE
MAINTAIN MEMBERSHIP IN THEIR
PRIOR NON ACADEMIC SENATE
BARGAINING UNIT. THIS
ARRANGEMENT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE IT WOULD POTENTIALLY
CAUSE ACADEMIC SENATE FACULTY
WHO MANAGE AND SUPERVISE
INSTRUCTORS TO BE REPRESENTED
ALONGSIDE THE SAME NON ACADEMIC
SENATE INSTRUCTORS. THE SENATE
GREATLY VALUES THE WORK
INSTRUCTORS DO BUT INSTRUCTORS
SERVE A DIFFERENT FUNCTION AT
THE UNIVERSITIES AND ACADEMIC
SENATE FACULTY.
RESPONSIBILITIES OF INSTRUCTORS
IS FOCUSED ON TEACHING.
ACADEMIC SENATE FACULTY HAVE
OBLIGATIONS OF TEACHING
RESEARCH AND SERVICE AND
IMPORTANTLY OF HELPING TO
MANAGE THE UNIVERSITY OF SHARED
GOVERNANCE. AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE GOP MENTIONED THE
ACADEMIC SENATE CAN ALREADY
UNIONIZED AND ALREADY HAS EACH
TO SANTA CRUZ. FINALLY A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY WOULD PROHIBIT
THE ACADEMIC SENATE FROM
EXTENDING SENATE MEMBERSHIP TO
ANYONE WITH SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR DUTIES AS REPRESENTED
ACADEMIC EMPLOYEES. THIS IS PUT
THIS IN PERMITTED. THE SENATE
COULD NOT MODIFY ELIGIBILITY
FOR MEMBERSHIP IN THE FUTURE
FOR EXAMPLE TO SUPPORT FACULTY
YOU SEEK TO ADJUST THEIR WORK
LIFE BALANCE. RECEIVE
CALIFORNIA IS PROUD TO BE PART
OF THE FINEST SYSTEM OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE UNITED
STATES. BUT THIS BILL ENDANGERS
THE ABILITY OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE BACK ULTI TO PARTICIPATE
IN SHARED GOVERNANCE WHICH
UNDERLIES THE HIGH LEVEL OF
TEACHING RESEARCH AND SERVICE
THAT IS CARRIED OUT BY SENATE
FACULTY. AND IS CRITICAL TO THE
ECONOMY AND WELL BEING OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE UC
ACADEMIC SENATE URGES YOU TO
VOTE NO ON A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. I
DON'T SEE ANY- ONE THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. I SEE NONE NEXT WE'LL
DO IT THIS IS NOT POSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR. IT WAS
TO COME IN OPPOSITION IN A
PRESS ONE UNTIL ABOUT THIS TIME.
THE GOVERNMENT. I CAN'T. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU FOR
GOING TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. HEARING AND SEEING
THEM- MISS REAVIS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ON YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND WE WILL
HAVE A MOTION AT SOLDIER THE
MOTION THE SECOND. MISTER
CALDERON MAKES MOTION MR VOEPEL
MAKES A SECOND- MADAM SECRETARY
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
AYE VOEPEL. NOT BOTH. VOEPEL
NOT BUILDING VOTING CALDERON
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL.
FIGURE. TWO THREE VOTES ON CALL
MISS REDUCE YOUR BILLS ALL CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE NOT
MOVING TO THE NEXT LEVEL IN
JUST STARTING WITH A. B. FIVE
FIVE ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL ALREADY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURR'S THANK FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL TODAY. AB FIVE FIVE ONE
WOULD AUTHORIZE CAL STIRS TO
OFFER AND ACCEPT CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR TRADITIONAL TAX DEFERRED
IRA AND ROTH IRA PLANS.
INCLUDING ROLLOVER FROM ANY
ELIGIBLE RETIREMENT PLAN INTO
THOSE ARE A PLANTS. THE BILL
WOULD ENABLE WILL ENABLE CAL
STIRS TO RECEIVE CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM ELIGIBLE MEMBERS FORMER
OUTDOOR MEMBERS WHO ARE RETIRED
AND THEIR SPOUSES FOR THE IRA
IRA PLANS. CULTURES WILL
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE MEMBERS
TO COMPARE PRODUCTS AND CHOOSE
WHAT THEY- WANT FOR THE
FINANCIAL ADVISER BELIEVES IS
BEST FOR THEIR NEEDS. WITH ME
TODAY PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS
MERRY AND ACTUALLY DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WITH
CHARACTERS AND JENNIFER BAKER.
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU THREE TO
MOVE THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
AND FIRST UP IS MARYANNE ASHLEY.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS MERION ASHLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
CHARACTERS IS THE SPONSOR OF
THE MEASURE. WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THAT WILL ASSIST CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS WITH THEIR
SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT SAVINGS
OPTIONS AND ALSO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY AT THE COLDWATER.
CHARACTERS MISSION IS SECURING
THE FINANCIAL FUTURE
ENTERTAINING THE TRUST OF
CALIFORNIA EDUCATORS AND TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE OFFER
HYBRID RETIREMENT SYSTEM WITH
DEFINED BENEFIT CASH BALANCE
AND VOLUNTARY DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLANS. AND WHILE
THE DEFINED BENEFIT PLAN IS A
GREAT BENEFIT FOR CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS IT IS WITH IT EXCUSE
ME IS A QUICK SPECTER TO ONLY
REPLACE ABOUT 50% OF OUR
MEMBERS. AND IF THE CAREER
EARNING. AND ADDITION
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATORS DO
NOT CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIAL
SECURITY. SO THEY WILL NOT
RECEIVE A FOCAL SECURITY
BENEFIT PRODUCT CHARACTERS
COVERED EMPLOYMENT. THAT'S
CHARACTERS RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
HELP SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT
SAVINGS AND WE REALLY ENCOURAGE
OUR MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE IN A
SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT SAVINGS
PLAN. CURRENTLY CHARACTERS
OFFERS FOR A THREE D. PARK AT
THE SEVENTY ROXBORO THREE B.
AND RAPPORT FIFTY SEVENTY
PLANTS WHAT POKOK BE
STRUCTURED. AND UNLIKE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS WE DO NOT CHARGE
COMMISSION AND THERE ARE NO
PENALTIES OR SURRENDER CHARGES
IF A PARTICIPANT WANTS TO LEAVE
OUR PROGRAM. AND ROLLOVER OR
EXCHANGE THEIR FUNDS ELSEWHERE.
WE ALSO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
OFFER A ROTH IRA. HOWEVER WHAT
FINDING IS THAT EVERY MONTH WE
HAVE ANYWHERE FROM FIFTY TO A
HUNDRED MEMBERS ASKING ABOUT
OUR OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTRIBUTE
OR ROLL OVER TO A CHARACTERS
IRA. FIXES WHY WE'RE SPEAKING
THAT LEGISLATION RESPOND FOR
MEMBERS AND TO HELP THEM MEET
THEIR RETIREMENT SAVINGS ALL.
INTENT OF THE CHARACTERS ARE
RIGHT IF NOT FOR PARTICIPANTS
TO USE IN LIEU OF A FOUR OH
THREE B. R. FOR FIFTY SEVEN
PLANS WE'RE VERY WELL AWARE OF
SOME OF THE ADVANTAGES. OF SOME
PLANTS. BUT RATHER IT IS MEANT
TO AUGMENT THE PLAN. CHARACTERS
THE RETIREMENT. PLAN
PARTICIPANTS AND OUR MEMBERS
WITH ONE ON ONE APPOINTMENT.
WEBINARS WORKSHOPS VIDEOS. AND
PRINT MATERIALS. SO THAT OUR
MEMBERS AND PARTICIPANTS ARE
ABLE TO GET ASSISTANCE AND
EDUCATION REGARDING THE SAVINGS
OPTIONS WE OFFER. AND THE
BENEFITS THAT EACH TYPE OF
PLAN. OF THE DAY ALONG WITH THE
HELP OF BURKE FINANCIAL
ADVISORS. CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AND CHOOSE A PLAN
THAT BEST SUITS THEIR
RETIREMENT NEEDS AND GOALS. IF
A CHARACTERS TO A TRADITION IRA
WILL NOT ELIMINATE A NUMBER
ABILITY TO ENROLL IN A FOUR OH
THREE B. OR FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
PLAN. IT WILL BE A MEANS FOR
CAL STARS PROVIDES THE SAME LOW
COST SERVICES OFFERED VIA THE
CHARACTERS FOR A THREE D. AND
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN PLAN. TO THOSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
AND ASKING FOR A CALPERS FIVE
OPTION FOR CONTRIBUTION OR
ROLLOVER PURPOSES. CHAPTER THE
CALL WE DEDICATED THE SECURING
THE FINANCIAL FUTURE OF OUR
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT WITNESS IS
PREFERRED BAKER. IT HAPPENED
THIS IS JENNIFER BAKER AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WHO PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE WHICH
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT TOOL FOR TEACHERS.
BY PROVIDING TEACHERS WITH BOTH
THE OPTION OF CHOOSING AN IRA
AS WELL AS THE NOCTIVA THIS
MEASURE WOULD ALLOW TEACHERS
THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS FOR DIVERSE
THAT FIND THEIR LONG TERM
RETIREMENT STATING. AB FIVE
FIFTY ONE WOULD ALSO ALLOW
ROLLOVER ALLOWING RETIREES TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF DIFFERENT
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS. THE COST OF
RETIREMENT- INCREASING MAKING
IT MORE IMPORTANT FOR TEACHERS
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
VEHICLES PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF THE FACT THAT BABY BOOMERS
ARE VULNERABLE TO FEDERAL
SOCIAL SECURITY ASSETS. WHICH
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS THAT EDUCATORS STATE
IN TWO. THOUSAND FORTUNATE THAT
THOSE IN THE FINANCIAL SECTOR
ARE TRYING TO FIGHT FOR
COMPETITION INSTEAD OF FOCUSING
ON IMPROVING THEIR OWN PRODUCT
TO MAKE THEMSELVES MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO OUR MEMBERS. I
FALLING COMP MAY BE GOOD FOR
WEALTHY WALL STREET INVESTORS
BUT OUR FOCUS IS ON WHICH GOOD
FOR TEACHERS RETIREMENT
SECURITY. RIDING THE TOOL
TEACHERS AND RETIRED TEACHERS
NEED TO HAVE A MORE SECURE
RETIREMENT IT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY NEED RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT THE LARGEST GROWING
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION IS
THE SENIOR POPULATION. IF
CURRENT AND FUTURE SENIOR KERR
ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE IT WILL
HAVE AN ECONOMIC DRAG ON
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. THIS
SIMPLE BUT EFFECTIVE MEASURE
IT'S FORWARD THINKING AND WILL
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S RETIRED
TEACHERS WILL BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THEIR OWN RETIREMENT SECURITY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. AND EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU MAKES
WE MOVED IT WOULDN'T SUPPORT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ANYONE IS IN SUPPORT. SINGA
WOULD WITNESSES SUPPORT ON THE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION. LCDA WILL
MOVE AWARENESS IS ON THE PHONE
WHO WERE IN SUPPORT OPERATOR.
WHICH TO ME COMING INTO PORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WHAT SERVICES FOR AB
FIVE FIVE ONE. AND THERE'S NO
WINNING Q. OKAY THANK YOU
REMOVED WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FIRST UP IS GEORGE MILLER. MR
MILLER. MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
GEORGE MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF PENSION
PROFESSIONALS AND ACTUARIES AN
AFFILIATE OF THE AMERICAN
RETIREMENT ASSOCIATION WITH
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA. OR BY
CONSULTING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES TO EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS
AND SPONSORS OF RETIREMENT
PLANS. IS ON THEIR BEHALF THE I
MUST RESPECTFULLY CLOSE EIGHT
FIVE FIVE ONE TODAY. AB FIVE
FIVE ONE WHAT SENSUALLY ALLOWS
TERRORISTS TO BE A LEAD
GENERATOR FOR A WALL STREET
CREATED FINANCIAL SERVICES
FIRM. BOY NOT UNLIKE ANY OF OUR
OTHER MEMBERS. THE PBLIC
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY LOW COST
OPTIONS TO SAVE FOR RETIREMENT
TO WORK PLACE FOR A THREE D.
AND FOUR FIFTY SEVEN BASED
SOLUTIONS WHICH ARE SUPERIOR IN
MANY WAYS. TO INVESTING IN IRIS
IN ADDITION CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVATE SECTOR RETIREMENT
INDUSTRY OFFERS ANY EMPLOYEE
WORKING ON PUBLIC EDUCATION
RESOURCES TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
RETIREMENT COVERAGE THROUGH AN
IRA. FOR THESE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FIVE
FIVE ONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
YIELD THE BALANCE OF MY TIME IF
THERE'S ANY TO MISTER NORWOOD
THANK YOU JOHN NORWOOD'S OF
NEXT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF
OF AMERICAN FIDELITY INSURANCE
GROUP- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL THIS
WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME THIS
FIRST SERVICE WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED TO OFFER PRODUCTS TO
NON TEACHERS THE BILL ALLOWS
JURORS TO OFFER PRODUCTS. AND I
REPEAL PLANS INDEPENDENT I
REPLY AND TO- TEACHERS FORMER
TEACHERS AND ASSOCIATED
PERSONNEL AND SPOUSES OF
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION PERSONNEL
AND FORMER TEACHER TEACHERS- WE
REALLY QUESTION THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO INNER. WHAT IS A
VERY COMPETITIVE FIELD
CURRENTLY FOR INDIVIDUAL IRA
PLANS THAT IS WELL SERVED BY
FINANCIAL SERVICES FIRMS THAT
OFFER EVERYTHING FROM THE
LOWEST COST PLANS TO FINANCIAL
SERVICES ESPECIALLY WHERE THERE
IS NO ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES.
PRIVATE PLANS FOR. THE EMPLOYER
STIRRERS REALLY STANDS IN THE
PLACE OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYER IN OFFERING RETIREMENT
PLANS. THERE ARE PLAN LEVEL
RULES THAT GOVERNED THE
ADMINISTRATION OF PRE TAX
SALARY DEFERRED PLANS LIKE
PENSIONS FOUR THREE B. AND FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN PROGRAMS THESE
PLANS ARE TO BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE EMPLOYER. IN THESE CASES.
pTO DICTATE THE PRODUCTS TO BE
OFFERED AND WHO'S GOING TO
OFFER THEM BECAUSE THEY EITHER
HAVE THE EITHER MATCH
CONTRIBUTIONS OR THEY HAVE A
DUTY UNDER FEDERAL LAW TO
ADMINISTER THE PLANTS. BUT I
RISEN ROTH IRAS ALL DIFFERENT
ANIMAL- THEY ARE INDIVIDUAL
PLANS FUNDED WITH AFTER TAX
DOLLARS OF THE EMPLOYEE ONLY
THERE'S NO INVOLVEMENT OF THE
EMPLOYER AND SUCH PLANS AND
THERE'S NO. REQUIREMENT OR
MINISTRY REQUIREMENTS ON THE
EMPLOYER. I THINK WE ALL SHARE
THE CONCERN THE TEACHERS GET
THE BEST POSSIBLE ADVICE AND
ARE OFFERED A FULL GAMUT OF
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR A SUCCESSFUL
RETIREMENT. FINANCIAL SERVICES
FIRMS CAN OFFER A FULL ARRAY OF
THESE SERVICES. BUT WE FEEL
THAT. AB FIVE FIVE ONE PROVIDE
STIRRERS WHO WILL BE OFFERING
PROPRIETARY PRODUCTS THROUGH
WHAT IS LIKELY A LIMITED BROKER
DEALER A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
TO USE WAGE SLOTS. AND THEIR
LONG TERM RELATIONSHIP TO TEACH
WITH TEACHERS TO OFFER LIMITED
PRODUCTS THAT MIGHT OR MIGHT
NOT E IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE TEACHER AND THESE
ASSOCIATED. PERSONNEL WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO DETERMINE HOW
TO USE THEIR FUNDS OR THAT OF
THEIR SPOUSE OR- THEIR PARTNERS
FILES- LASTLY FEDERAL
REGULATORS HAVE DEVELOPED A
WHOLE LITANY OF GUIDELINES DUE
DILIGENCE. AND DISCLOSURES
INCLUDING DISCLOSURE OF THIRD
PARTY RELATIONSHIPS. THESE ARE
MANDATED SPECIFICALLY FOR IRAS
AND ROTH IRAS IT'S UNCLEAR IN
THIS BILL. ARE WHETHER THESE
APPLY DESTROYERS AND THEIR
CHOSEN ADMINISTRATOR. OUR
BROKERS ARE HOLD LICENCES BY
INSURANCE IS USUALLY HOLD
INSURANCE IS KERRY LICENSES AND
MUST FOLLOW THESE GUIDELINES
RULES. AND FULL DISCLOSURES AND
ARE SUBJECT TO ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS IF THEY DIDN'T. SO FOR
THE THREE- RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
TIME WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
DISCUSSIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND MORE
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THAT OPPOSITION THIS BILL.
REMOVED OF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. I DON'T SEE ANY- NEXT
MOVE THEM WHEN THIS IS NOT
POSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
OPERATOR. HE WAS TOO COMMON
OPPOSITION DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO
AT THIS TIME. PURSUE THE TO
LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MOVING ONTO
LINE TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY APOLOGIES FOR BEING OUT OF
ORDER THIS IS SEPT BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT GO TO
LINE TWO EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GLAD.
NINE TO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE TELL ME YOUR PHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
ALSO APOLOGIZE MY TIMING WE ARE
IN TALKS WITH PART OF THE STUFF.
MEXICO TO LINE UP TO SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
APOLOGIES WELL MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND SUPPORT STAFF.
AT THE TIME AS NOTED IN Q.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SINGER HANNAH- SILVA
RODRIGUEZ WAS LIKE TO CLOSE ON
YOUR BILL PERSPECTIVES RIVAL.
OKAY- OUR MOTION. OKAY MISTER
COOLEY IN THE BILL THIS CALL
WAS A SECOND- YOU KNOW IT'S
REAL QUICK I PUT A LOT OF
THOUGHT TO THIS ON BOTH SIDES
THE ARGUMENT SUPPORT FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION- MESSAGING
SUPPORT AB FIVE FIVE ONE TODAY
IS TWO FOLD AND SIMPLE. FIRST I
VOTED FOR THE SIMILAR BILL VERY
SIMILAR BILL MISS COMMITTEE
LAST SESSION THE BILL PASSES
COMMITTEE FIVE TO TWO. OTHER
PERSONAL FINANCIAL SITUATION OF
WORKERS SINCE THAT TIME HAS
GOTTEN WORSE NOT BETTER FOR
MOST. IT WOULD MAKE ABSOLUTELY
NO SENSE FOR ME NOT SUPPORTED
TODAY. S. SECONDLY THE AVERAGE
DEFINED BENEFIT FOR CALPERS
RETIREE IS 50% OF THEIR WORKING
WAGE. TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE
TEACHERS NOT RECEIVES ALSO
CARRY LIKE MOST RETIREES DO.
THE FIRM BELIEVER IN A DEFINED
BENEFIT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
OTHEREMPLOYEE INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. EDUCATORS ARE
INTELLIGENT. I BELIEVE THEY CAN
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ON
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES ARE
BEST FOR THEM. I BELIEVE EVERY
TIME INVESTMENT SHOULD PROVIDE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES BOTH OF THE
VEHICLES AND WHICH THEY CHOOSE
TO INVEST. IN HIS A TUESDAY
VEST WITH FOR THESE REASONS I
RECOMMEND YOU CAN AYE VOTE-
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU TAKE
THE REMOTE CALL ROLE PLEASE THE
MOTION IS THE PAST AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. COOPER HI
COOPER AYE VOEPEL NO VOEPEL NO
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL C. R.
TO. THE BILL IS FOR ONE TO ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ THAT
BILLS ON CALL- NEXT WE'LL GO
WITH THAT SB SIX FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BERS. AS
YOU'RE AWARE THERE'S A HUGE
SHORTAGE OF LICENSED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND PRACTITIONERS
AND OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THIS
HAS GONE ON FOR QUITE SOME TIME
AND A SHOWN TO BE MORE CRITICAL
NOW MORE THAN EVER DURING
COLBERT NINETEEN. A. B. SIX
FIFTEEN WITH SIMPLY PROVIDE
MINIMUM PLAN RIGHTS TO MEDICAL
AND DENTAL PLACE TO WORK FOR A
HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYER.
THESE EMPLOYEES WHO WORK IN
HIGHER EDUCATION TO GET THE
SKILLS NECESSARY FOR LIFE
SCENES ARE NOT AFFORDED BASIC
RIGHTS REGARDING DISCIPLINE OR
TERMINATION OF EMPLOYMENT THAT
COULD NEGATIVELY. NEGATIVELY
IMPACT. IMPACT FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO
SOMETHING MINOR THAT ARE
RELATED TO. CLINICAL PRACTICE
OR ACADEMICS. BECAUSE OF THE
ONGOING CRISIS IN HEALTHCARE
TODAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
MINOR SUBJECTIVE DECISIONS
DON'T HARM THE FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. OF
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TODAY. ALL IN
THE TOUGH FIGHT RESPOND TO
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE MATT
LATE WITH S. A. U. AND DR ANNA
YEAH. FIRST UP IS MET LATE
WEDNESDAY. HELLO THIS IS NOT A
J. ON BEHALF OF AS YOU
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY SIX FIFTEEN
SO THE INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE GONE
THROUGH YEARS OF MEDICAL
TRAINING OFTEN EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT THAT ARE AND ARE
NOW IN THEIR RESIDENCY PROGRAM
HAVE ACCESS TO BASIC DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS. ALL OTHER
EMPLOYEES AT THE UC HOP ACCESS
TO THESE BASIC RIGHTS TO ENSURE
THAT DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS ARE
JUDICATA BY NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY
ARBITERS- THESE ARBITRATORS ARE
IMPORTANT BACKSTOPS ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES CAREER IS NOT
DERAILED DUE TO A DISAGREEMENT
WITH THEIR EMPLOYER. PROGRAM
MISTER OFTEN OFTEN CITE THE BIG
EXPANSIVE TURN UNPROFESSIONAL
TO TAKE ACTIONS AGAINST
RESIDENTS WHO SPEAK UP ABOUT
ISSUES RELATED TO PATIENT CARE
MORE FACE SAFETY ISSUES. THE
VISION MUST BE ABLE TO SPEAK UP
FOR THEIR PATIENCE ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY DISAGREE WITH THEIR
PROGRAM MINISTRY- WITHOUT FEAR
THAT DOING SO WILL ENDANGER
THEIR YEARS OF WORK AND THEIR
FUTURE LIVELIHOOD. FORT WAYNE
PROCESS RIGHTS FOR RESIDENT
PHYSICIANS IS NOT A NEW
CONCEPT- YEAH YOU HAD TO
PROCESS RIGHT INCREASE AT FIFTY
SIX OTHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
NATIONALLY INCLUDING. ONE AT
NINE YOU SEE HOSPITALS- IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS A STANDARD
THIS IS A STANDARD PRACTICE TO
ADDRESS LABOR DISPUTES- AND IN
FACT A NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY FACT
FINDER RECENTLY FOUND THAT- THE
UC SHOULD GIVE THESE RIGHTS TO
RESIDENTS FROM. THIS INCLUDING
ALL SAY THAT WE ARE CONTINUING
TO HAVE ONGOING PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL BY ENSURING THAT
RESIDENTS HAVE THE BASIC DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE BROUGHT AND
SHOW RESIDENTS CAN SPEAK UP FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR PATIENTS.
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION
FROM THEIR EMPLOYER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BUT
THANK YOU NEXUS DOCTOR ON A
YACHT. HELLO I'M DR ANNA YAP
THE RESIDENTS OF THE XIN AT
UCLA. I'VE GONE THROUGH FOUR
YEARS OF UNDERGRAD IN FOUR
YEARS OF MEDICAL SCHOOL AND I
AM NOW IN MY THIRD YEAR
PRESIDENCY. UNLIKE MOST
RESIDENTS I HAVE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN MEDICAL SCHOOL THAT. THING
RESIDENCIA HAVE MALE PATIENT
LOAD OF WORK AT THE FRONT LINE
POSITION AS I BECOME AN EXPERT
IN MY FIELD BEFORE I COME FULLY
BOARD CERTIFIED. AS LEARNERS
THE RESIDENTS ARE PROTECTED
WOULD YOU PROCESS WHEN IT COMES
THE ACADEMIC AND CLINICAL
MATTERS HOWEVER AS EMPLOYEES
WHO NEED TO FINISH RESIDENCY
WHICH CAN LAST ANYWHERE FROM
THREE NINE YEARS. TO BECOME A
FULLY BOARD CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN
OUR ENTIRE MEDICAL COULD BE
LOST BASED ON THE OPINION OF
ONE PERSON THINKING WHERE I'M
PROFESSIONAL. WITHOUT DUE
PROCESS IN THE UC SYSTEM.
PROFESSIONALISM IS OFTEN
TAINTED WITH BIAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY WEAPONIZED
AGAINST FEMALE PHYSICIANS AND
PHYSICIANS OF COLOR AND BECAUSE
IT CAN BE USED AGAINST US BUT
WE ADVOCATE. TO CREATE A
MEDICINE TO BECOME A PHYSICIAN
WE SUCH INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE GOOD
AT FOLLOWING DIRECTIONS. AND
DON'T NECESSARILY MAKE WEIGHT.
AND DURING CODE THIS IS PLAINLY
OBVIOUS CONFOUND OUR DUTY
POSITIONS ACROSS THE NATION
FIRED FOR SPEAKING UP AND
STATING THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH PP. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SPONSORING EIGHTY SIX ONE FIVE.
SO THAT RESIDENTS IN THE UC
SYSTEM CANNOT BASIC DUE PROCESS
WHEN IT COMES TO TERMINATION
FOR REASONS OF PROFESSIONALISM
NON. ACADEMIC NON CLINICAL. SO
I EIGHTY SIX FUNDS. WOULD US
THE TO UP AND PATIENT AB. AND
HOW CAPITA WITHOUT THE THREAT
OF. OUR ENTIRE MY CAREER. I
THINK THE MEDICINE IS. MORE
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
JOINING THE OF THE- ONE. BUT
YOU IS SLOW AND ONE OF THE
HURDLES WE FACE IS BEING DEEMED
UNPROFESSIONAL AND THE EYES OF
THOSE WHO HAVE SO MUCH POWER
OVER OUR FUTURE. ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE A DO YOU A FAVOR DUE
PROCESS. WILL HELP TO BALANCE
THAT POWER AND ENSURE THAT OUR
HIGH QUALITY DOCTOR IS NOT
BEING CAST ASIDE BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT. WITH THE MOLD OF THE
STEREOTYPICAL DR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR IDOL ON EIGHTY
SIX ONE FIVE. THANK YOU. NOW
REMOVED WITH. IN THE- ROOM IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIX ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I AM
JOHN RUN IN. THE V. P. OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE UC HAVE T.
THE UNION REPRESENTS LABOR
INTELLECTUALS DELIVERS
CALIFORNIA AND I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. SINGLENESS IS IN THE
HEARING ROOM ORGAN MOVED
WITNESSES IN THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. SAYING NONE WE MOVED
WITH THIS IS A SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINE OPERATOR. DAVIDO
WHOSE MAIN COMMON IN A PRESS
ONE AND ZERO WE GO TO LINE TWO
NINETY TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CONNECT TO THE TIMELINE TO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL YOUNG THE MAP TO
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION TEACHERS
HERE IN SUPPORT. ONE TWO ONE
THREE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS AND
ALL OF THE SHOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. TO GO TO LINE THREE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VALVE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THE
COURT. MICROCLINE THREE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO NINE THREE- TWO FORTY
FIVE NINE TO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MANAGEMENT AFTER THE
GRANT BUT AT A LOCAL THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE IN SUPPORT OF- SB.
SIX THANK YOU TO FROM HAVE ONE
MORE.
NINE THREE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
KAREN NUMBER EXPRESSED BUDGET
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. AND WE HAVE NO
NOTHING Q. THANK YOU OPERATOR
REMOVED WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OF THE MEASURE A FIRST UP WE
HAVE MICHAEL DARD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
MICHAEL THE DOG FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFF
THE PRESIDENT. ETHIOPIA HAS AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON A. B. SIX FIFTEEN
PROPOSITION LIKE LAST YEAR TO
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF
ACADEMIC AND CLINICAL MATTERS
IN THE BILL. BLACK WITH LAST
YEAR'S BILL WERE WORKING IN
GOOD FAITH WITH THE OFTEN
SPONSOR TO FIND A WAY TO
PROTECT PATIENT SAFETY AND- TO
ADD ADDITIONAL DUE PROCESS. YOU
HE IS NOT OPPOSED TO
ARBITRATION FOR GRADUATE
MEDICAL STUDENTS. ARE RESIDENTS
ALREADY HAVE SIGNIFICANT DUE
PROCESS NEEDS PROCEDURES THAT
THEM FOR CERTAIN AFFIRMED. BY
THE COURT AND ARE REQUIRED BY
OUR ACCREDITATION AND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WITH RESIDENTS.
RESIDENTS HAVE MULTIPLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO APPEAL
DECISIONS AND OVERSIGHT. BY
THE- ACCREDITATION COUNCIL OF
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM. PREVENTS ANY ARBITRARY
OR CAPRICIOUS DECISION MAKING.
NO SIGNIFICANT DISCIPLINE OR
TERMINATION ACTION IS MADE BY
ONE IT PROVIDES ARE ALONE.
HOWEVER THE UNIVERSITY NEEDS TO
ENSURE A PHYSICIAN EDUCATOR AND
DISCIPLINE WHEN NECESSARY. AND
THAT ADVANCEMENT OF GRADUATION
FROM THE PROGRAM IS BASED ON AN
EVALUATION. IN THE MEDICAL-EDUCATION PROGRAM NOT AT
EMPLOYMENT ARBITRATION.
NEVERTHELESS WE'RE HOPEFUL WE
CAN CLARIFY ACADEMIC AND
CLINICAL MATTERS IN THE BILL TO
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS. BUT I
WANT TO MENTION HOW PROUD AND
APPRECIATIVE WE ARE AS AN
INSTITUTION OF OUR MEDICAL
RESIDENTS. OVER THE LAST YEAR
THEY'VE GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND
SHOWING AN UNBELIEVABLE LEVEL
OF DEDICATION AND SELF
SACRIFICE- AND I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M HOPEFUL WE'LL GET
TO A- GOOD RESOLUTION ON THE
BILL BEFORE TOO LONG. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
FIFTEEN SO. WHEN THIS IS IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION. I
NONE. OF THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
ON THE REMOTE VIDEO STATION. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LESS MOVED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE OPERATOR. IT WILL BE
IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DON'T HAVE ANY IN
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
REMEMBER THE COMMITTEE. I KNOW
WE HAVE A FIRST BY MR BONTA IS
AND THE SECOND BY THIS CALDERON-
DID OVER THE QUESTIONS- SILVA
RODRIGUEZ WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
IN YOUR BILL. YES RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY CAN THE ROLL CALL
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS THE PAST
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE VOEPEL
NO. VOEPEL NO CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES COOLEY. I'VE COOLEY
AYE O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I SAY
ARE TO. THE VOTE IS FIVE TO ONE
MR REDUCE YOUR BILLS ON CALL.
THE NEXT BILLS WERE ON A BEEF
EIGHT FORTY FIVE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE OR CREATE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
CERTAIN FRONT LINE WORKERS THAT
A CORPORATE NINETEEN RELATED
ILLNESS. CONTRACTED ON THE JOB
SHALL BE ELIGIBLE FOR IN
SERVICE DISABILITY RETIREMENT.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE IN EFFECT
UNTIL JULY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THESE EMPLOYEES INCLUDE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS FIREFIGHTERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT A PUBLIC SERVANTS
TO NAME JUST A FEW. THIS BILL
WOULD FINANCIAL PROTECT THOSE
WHO HAVE HELPED KEEP OUR LIGHTS
ON OUR WATER RUNNING OUR FOOD
STOCKED ENTRY OR ILLNESSES AS
WELL AS OUR LOVED ONES IN THE
MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC. WITH ME
TODAY IS TERRY BERNARD FOR
REPRESENTING SO YOU TO TOUGH
FRONT SUPPORT AND SPEAK TO ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND
CALLING IN THIS CHRISTIE
BEAUMONT'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS MISTER BRENNAN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TERRY BRENNAN
ABOUT HOW FAST YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA I THINK THE AUTHOR
DID A GREAT JOB OF EXPLAINING
THIS AS WELL AS THE- ANALYSIS
VERY DETAILED. WHAT THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY DOES IS SAY IF
YOU'VE QUALIFIED FOR WORKERS
COMP. UNDER THE SAME
CONDITIONS. AS JUVENTUS OFF OF
YOUR MEDICAL. TREATMENTS YOUR
OCCUPATIONAL RETURN TO WORK
EFFORTS AND YOU CANNOT RETURN
TO WORK YOUR DISABLED FROM YOUR
JOB YOU DO NOT HAVE TO VAN. RE
EXAMINE WHERE YOU'VE GOT THAT
DISABILITY IF YOU QUALIFIED FOR
WORKERS COMP YOU WOULD QUALIFY
FOR IN SERVICE DISABILITY IT'S
AS SIMPLE AS THAT WE PASSED THE
LAW FOR WORKERS COMP. IT'S TIME
WE TOOK CARE OF THOSE PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T RETURN TO WORK FOR
ONE REASON OR ANOTHER. SO WE
ARE DRIVE VOTE I'M AVAIL FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU NEXT IS CHRISTY BOMA. MS
BOWMAN ARE YOU THERE. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO WITH
THIS IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM I SEE NO MORE
MODERATE THIS IS VIA REMOTE
VIDEO STATION SUPPORT. LCD THIS
MOVE THE PHONE LINE WHAT IS THE
SUPPORT. OPERATING WITNESSES
SPORT. WHAT THE SUPPORT BY TWO
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS SEPT BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EDUCATORS THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. IF THE FIRST.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. WELL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS I AM. THE A SECOND
SETTLED MISTER BRENNAN WITH
YOUR INDULGENCE I'M HAPPY TO DO
SO SURE. FOR THE. HI MR JERABEK
DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS REPRESENTING MORE
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL WITH
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE- WE
ARE GRATEFUL MY NUMBERS ARE SO
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
PROVIDE PROVIDING A WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTION. FOR
FIREFIGHTERS EMS WORKERS AND
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS ADOPTED
LAST YEAR GREAT POPULOUS
GOVERNANCE IMPORTANT SIGNATURE-
BUT IF YOU KNOW THE VERY
WORKERS ARE STILL ON THE FRONT
LINES AND HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
PUT THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY.
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THE
pBAFFLING AND DEVASTATING
SYMPTOMS THAT CURRENTLYPREVENT. OUR MEMBERS FROM DOING
THE JOB THEY LOVE AND MAY BE
FORCED TO RETIRE DUE TO.
ILLNESS I WAS ONLY SIX MONTHS
OF THEIR AVAILABLE RESEARCHERS
ARE ALREADY STARTING TO
IDENTIFY SERIOUS AND
DEBILITATING EFFECTS FROM THE
DISEASE- THEY ALREADY BECAUSE
OF THEIR EXPOSURE FIREFIGHTERS
IN THEIR CAREERS TOUGHER FROM
COMPROMISED RESPIRATORY SYSTEM.
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT FORTY
FIVE WOULD SIMPLY SEPARATE THE
SAME WORKERS COVERED BY THE CO
THE NINETEEN CONSUMPTION OF
RETIRED IN A KIND OF THE
NINETEEN RELATED ILLNESS OR
INJURY ARE PRESUMED TO BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR AN IN SERVICE OR
INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY
RETIREMENT THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE ASSURANCE TO THE
MEN AND WOMEN. IN THE FIELD
PROVIDING SERVICES WORKERS YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU FOR INDULGING
SEARCHER THANK YOU. OPERATED WE
HAVE MANY MORE COLORS. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN SUPPORT FIND
TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RICHARD MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MR WE HAVE A COUPLE HOURS
QUEUING UP JUST A MOMENT OKAY
OKAY.
OKAY AND LINE THREE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU THIS IS WHAT ACOSTA
WITH THE SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AIR
RAIL TRANSPORTATION WORKERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE ONE THREE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CALL QUERY WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL IT FORTY FIVE. HEY WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU REMOVED WITNESSES
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FORTY
FIVE. I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES A SUPPORT PRIMARY
ANYWHERE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. K. SINGLE ONE WHO
WILL REMOTE VIDEO STATION IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FORTY
FIVE. I DON'T SEE ANYONE- THIS
IS A PHONE OPERATOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. FORTY FIVE.
DOES NOT THE SENATE AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE DON'T HAVE ANY IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS. THAT WE HAVE A FIRST
BY MR BONTA IS. SECOND I MISSED
CALDERON- MR RODRIGUEZ WAS LIKE
TO MAKE A CLOSE BUT BROWN'S
FROM ABOUT. THE MIDDLE
SECRETARY TO RECALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS THE PERSON BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER AYE
HOOPER AYE VOEPEL FIVE VOEPEL I
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES. CERVANTES I COOLEY
COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL
I SAY ARE TO. SIX MISTER
RICHARD BILLS ON CALL.
MISERABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THIS CALDERON AB. TWO EIGHTY
NINE. THE PRESENTER BILL WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO EIGHTY NINE SEEKS TO ENSURE
FAIRNESS AND SCHOOL DISTRICT
MERIT SYSTEM ELECTIONS MERIT
SYSTEMS OR CIVIL SERVICE HIRING
SYSTEMS PREDICATED ON ATTAINING
A WELL QUALIFIED AND
REPRESENTATIVE WORKFORCE. TODAY
THERE ARE OVER NINETY K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS UTILIZING MERIT
SYSTEMS TO HIRE AND PROMOTE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. THESE
EMPLOYEES ARE DEFINED AS NON
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS PARA
EDUCATORS OR CUSTODIANS TO NAME
A FEW. EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES
THE ADOPTION AND REMOVAL OF
SCHOOL MERIT SYSTEMS BY
MAJORITY VOTE OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. THIS BILL WILL
CODIFY EQUITY FOR THESE
EMPLOYEES DURING MERIT SYSTEM
ELECTIONS AND ADDS IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT TO THE ELECTION
PROCESS HERE WITH ME REMOTELY
IS THE LAURA STRAND FLORES WITH
THE SCHOOL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND JOHN
BAIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL PERSONNEL COMMISSIONERS
ASSOCIATION. OR IS. MISS FLORES
RETIREMENT AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND NEVER MIND IF THE WARRANT
DURANT LARA'S I REPRESENT YES
WE ARE THE SPOTS WITH THE BABY
Q. EIGHT NINE. THE BILL
PROVIDES FAIRNESS AND MERIT
SYSTEM ELECTION. ASSEMBLY MANY
CIVIL SERVICE DEFENSE THAT
CLASSIFIED INFO PLEASE CAN VOTE
TO ESTABLISH DURING ELECTION.
BIGELOW ACTIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
FAIR TO CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
SENATE BILL GRAVITY THE
NETWORKING AND FOUR WAY. FIRST
AB TWO EIGHT NINE INSURANCE IF
WE COULD BALLOT ELECTION BY
PROHIBITING ADMINISTRATOR. FROM
MARKING BALLOT. WHEN
ADMINISTRATIVE MARK BALLOT IT
HAS A CHILLING EFFECT ON
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WHO FEAR
THAT THEIR VOTE WILL BE
TRACKED. BUT STILL ALLOWS A
UNIFORM STAMP YEAR AND FAT.
SECONDLY AB TWO EIGHT NINE
INCLUDE THE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE
ON THE TABULATION COMMITTEE
TABULATION COMMITTEE HELD THE
BALLOT AND REPORT THE RESULTS
TO THE GOVERNING BOARD. IT IS
INEQUITABLE TO ONLY HAVE A
DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE. THIRD THE
BILL INSURANCE THAT BOTH SIDES
ARE PROVIDED EQUITY IN ANY
DISTRICT ELECTION IN THE
INDICATION SO IT IS FAIR AND
BALANCED. AND FINALLY AB TWO
EIGHT NINE PERMITS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TOOK PART THE DATE
TIME AND LOCATION OF THE
ELECTION. SO THEY HAVE A VOICE
IN THE ELECTION PROCESS. EIGHTY
TWO NINE EIGHT NINE INSURANCE
SELECTIONS A FAIR TRANSPARENT
AND WITHOUT INTIMIDATION. I
HAVE FOR YOU RIGHT. THANK YOU
THE NEXT JOHN BAIRD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
FAMILY MY NAME IS JOHN BAIRD I
LIVE IN SAN DIEGO. I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONERS ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY NINETY
NINE MERIT SYSTEM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY I AM A PERSONAL
COMMISSIONER ON THE SAN DIEGO
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT.
PERSONNEL COMMISSION IN SAN
DIEGO. FURTHERMORE IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE IS
DOING GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
PASSED SB ONE SIXTY THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING LAW FOR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES I STARTED
WORKING FOR UNIONS
REPRESENTING. CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES COULD MERIT SYSTEM.
DISTRICTS TO ROUTE TWENTY EIGHT
GOAL WE DID SO FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS. THAT TIME WHILE A WALL
IN NUMEROUS REPRESENTATIONAL
EMERITUS COLLECTIONS RIGHT. ANY
ABUSES OF THE ELECTION PROCESS
BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THE LAST
TWO MARRIAGES THE MARGINS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS REFLECT SOME OF THE
MOST EGREGIOUS FLAGRANT
ENFORCEABLE ACTUALLY ABUSES.
FIVE SPEED DURING MY EMPLOYMENT.
THE OF AND TWO MILLION CAP
CAPTIVE AUDIENCE NOT THAT WOULD
USE. WHERE AND EMPLOYEES WERE
COMPELLED TO ATTEND MANAGEMENT
MEETINGS WHERE ONLY THE ANTI
MERIT SYSTEM POINT OF VIEW WAS
PRESENTED. ADDITIONALLY THE
CLASS THE PERSONNEL COMMISSION
DIRECTOR WHO SUPPORTED THE VERY
SYSTEM WAS TERMINATED.
PERSONNEL COMMISSION WHO ALSO
SUPPORTED THE MERS SYSTEM WAS
DE FUNDED. THESE ABUSES
HAPPENED IN BOTH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ALL OF THE FOREGOING
BARRISTERS TO MOLECULAR BRUISES
CORRIGAN INTIMIDATIONS. YOU ARE
THE REASONS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL PERSONNEL COMMISSION
DISPENSATION FULLY AND
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE
REASONABLE FAIR AND BALANCE OF
MEMONS THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE FORTY FIVE THREE
NINETEEN CONTAINED IN AB TWO
EIGHT NINE BY ASSEMBLY MAIL
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALDERON. THANK
YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU MEXICO MOVED
WITNESSES IN A HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHTY NINE.
SEEING NONE WOULD WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ON THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. I DON'T SEE ANY- WHEN
THIS IS ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF TWO A BETWEEN NINE. THE
OPERATOR. AND THEN FOR
SUPPORTER OF TRILLION. ONE
THREE OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES ST SAYS
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
WE GO TO ONE TO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SYSTEM
BROUGH I'M SPEAKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE HEARD YOUR AYE VOTE. WE GO
TO ONE TO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT. LINE
THREE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE SIXTY THREE A LINE
IS OPEN. LINE THREE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COOL QUERY
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO EIGHT NINE.
TWO ONE THREE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND CHEN
NUMBERS MENTALITY SHALL BE OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
WEATHER'S IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MELTER THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO EIGHTY
NINE. I SEE NONE IN THE- IN
ROOM. WHEN IS THIS OPPOSITION
ON THE REMOTE VIDEO STATION. I
DON'T SEE ANY. WHEN THIS IS ON
THE PHONE OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
EIGHTY NINE OPERATOR. IT CAN
OPPOSITION OF TWO EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO- NO
WANTING TO AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR. SENATE HEARING ON
SOME NUMBER CALDERON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE IN YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE SO WE'RE MOTION BY MISTER
COOLEY A SECOND BY MR BONTA IS-
MADAM ECRETARY CAN CALL ROLE
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS DEPRESSED
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL
RIGHT VOEPEL I CALDERON. AYE
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES
CERVANTES ARE COOLEY. HI COOLEY
AYE O'DONNELL. TOLD ON ALL I
SEE ARE TO. THE BILL HAS SIX
BOTH. MISTER CALDERON YOU BILLS
ON CALL NEXT UP IS MISTER
COOLEY. WITH AB. FIVE THIRTY
NINE. I WILL MOVE THE BILL. THE
SECOND. BURGER COLLEAGUES THE
THIS IS THIS BILL OF THIS IN
CASE OF WHAT GOES AROUND COMES
AROUND NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE I
WORKED ON A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO CHANGE OUR PENSION
SYSTEMS FROM A. LISTER
RESTRICTION AND WILL TRY TO
SEND MISTER CHAIRMAN TO
REASSURE YOU ARE TO SUBJECT IT
TO THE PRUDENT EXPERT STANDARD
THAT HAVE BEEN SET UP IN A
RESEARCH. THIS CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF CAL STIRS CALPERS.
TO THE- IMPOSITION OF FIDUCIARY
OBLIGATIONS TO THE PLAN
PARTICIPANTS AND HOW THEY WORK
THROUGH THEIR INVESTMENTS. THIS
BILL IS EXTENSIVE THAT VERY
IDEA. THAT IT WOULD AFFORD
GREATER FLEXIBILITY CAL STIRS.
TO WITHIN A PRODUCER
ENVIRONMENT. LOOK AT INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CAN YIELD
BENEFITS TO THEIR- OF.
BENEFICIARIES BUT STILL IN THIS
FIDUCIARY. ARRANGEMENT THIS
IDEA THAT OPPORTUNITIES EMERGE.
BETTER AN INVESTMENT MANAGER
UNDER FIDUCIARY RULES CAN SEIZE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
BENEFICIARIES. IS WHAT LED THE
APPROVAL PROP TWENTY ONE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR ACTUALLY
WROTE THE BALLOT ARGUMENT FOR
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. IT'S
DRIVING THIS THIS IS A GREAT
BILL. TO FOR A LITTLE LATITUDE%
TO CAL STIRS I DO HAVE A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. OF THE WE
DO HAVE. BROAD SUPPORT IN THE
HOURS LATE SO I WOULD INVITE
YOU TO JUMP IN- AND SPEAK
BRIEFLY JOHNSON MARTINEZ WAY.
MISLAID GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DISTRICTS ONE
MARTINEZ WAIT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM THE SPONSOR
OF AB FIVE THIRTY NINE I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER THERE
IT'S VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF
THE ISSUES. RELATED TO THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. SO WE'RE LOOKING WITH US
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY
NINE IN THE ROOM HEARING ROOM.
I SEE NONE. WHEN THIS IS
SUPPORT VIA REMOTE VIDEO. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE. OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OF AB.
FIVE THIRTY NINE OPERATOR. IF
YOUR SUPPORT FIVE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. WITH THE-
THANK YOU REMOVED WHEN THIS IS
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE THIRTY
NINE. I SEE NO ONE IN THE ROOM
HEARING ROOM. WHEN THIS ISN'T
OPPOSITION ALL REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
QUEUED UP AND WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE.
OPERATOR. IN YOUR IN OPPOSITION
FIVE THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP AS WELL.
K. WILL BRING BACK TO YOU
MISTER COOLEY FOR YOUR CLOTHES
I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
B. FIVE THIRTY NINE AND WE'VE
GOT A FIRST BY ME THE SECOND BY
MR BONTA ASSEMBLY. YES PARDON
IF I MAY. MISTER ROGERS SORRY
IF I MAY MISTER MISTER TERRY
THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR ON A
SUNDAY WE WILL. ATTEND OF THAT.
A MAN SECRETARY RECALL ROLE
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS DEPRESSED
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER. HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL
AYE VOEPEL AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL PRICE
THERE ARE TWO SIX VOTES MISTER
COOL YOUR BILL IS ON CALL GOOD
NEXT UP IS AB TWELVE NINETY
THREE MISTER COOLEY ALSO VERY
GOOD OUR VISITOR MEMBERS I AM
PRESENT AB TWELVE NINETY THREE
THIS IS A FAIRNESS BILL TO KIND
OF ROUND OUT THE LAW AS IT
APPLIES TO. A CLASS OF PENSION
AND RETIREE WITH A HI PENSION
BENEFIT THIS IS IT WOULD ALLOW
A JUDGE. AND THE JUDGE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS TENSIONS TO
THE OTHER INCOME LIMIT RETESTED
EACH YEAR. UNDER FEDERAL RULES
THERE'S A LOT THERE'S A CAP ON
HOW BIG A PINCH YOU CAN BE. R.
BUT THAT GETS ADJUSTED UNDER A
CAP BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REGULAR BASIS. OTHER RETIREES
IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR A HIGHER PENSION BECAUSE
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR
CAREER. CAN GET THEIR CAP.
RETESTED UNDER THIS FEDERAL AND
IN SMALL WAYS RECOUP SOME OF
THEIR EARLIER PAYMENTS AT A
PENSION. THIS SIMPLY EXTENDS IT
TO JUDGES IN FOR VARIETY
REASONS A SITTING JUDGE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO LONGER WILL WORK
FOR STATE AGENCY. AND IT WAS IN
THE JUDGE RETURNS US NUMBER
ONE. AND JUDGES FOR TAXES IN
ORDER TO THIS WILL HELP OF IS A
VERY NARROW BUT ITS FAIRNESS
AND IT'S NOT ACTUALLY BREAKING
NEW GROUND. TO EXTEND EXISTING
LAW TO THIS CLASS OF JUDGES
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU MR
COOLEY AND WE WITH A CELLPHONE
IN SUPPORT LIKE BELOW. WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIKE BELOW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT THIS IS A KIND OF A
COMPLICATED LITTLE ISSUE- AND-
HE HELPED US A LOT- VERY VERY
BRIEFLY THIS BILL DOES NO
CHANGE AT ALL TO WHAT A JUDGE
EARNS UNDER THE RETIREMENT
PLAN- YOU KNOW YOU ARE PROMISED
A CERTAIN AMOUNT UNDER THE
PLAN. BUT IF YOU HIT THE
FEDERAL CAPS IN INTERNAL
REVENUE CODE SECTION FOR
FIFTEEN YOU MAY NOT GET WHAT
YOU WERE PROMISED. SO YOU WOULD
TAKE A HIT YOU WOULD ACTUALLY
FOR FIT SOME OF YOUR BENEFITS.
WELL THAT FEDERAL LIMIT GOES UP
FROM TIME TO TIME AND SO THE
QUESTION IS CAN YOUR AMOUNT GO
UP WHEN THE FEDERAL LIMIT
INCREASES WELL FOR ALL OTHER
STATE EMPLOYEES IT DOES BUT I
THINK IT'S JUST A QUIRK IN THE
LAW I DON'T THINK THERE WAS ANY
POLICY REASON. FOR EXCLUDING
JUDGES SO ALL IT DOES IS ALLOW
IT JUDGE TO GET MORE OF WHAT
THE PROGRAM PROMISED THEM UNDER
THE RETIREMENT LAW- SO AT THE
MR COOLEY IS RIGHT IS VERY VERY
NARROW AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AND
I THOUGHT. THE YOU. WHO DO IN
THIS IS A PART OF THE HEARING
ROOM. I SEE NONE. ALLEN IS THE
SUPPORT ON THE REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. A SENIOR THERE EITHER.
WE'RE GONNA GO WITH THIS IS ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE NINETY THREE. OPERATOR.
IF SUPPORT AB TWELVE NINETY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU OPERATOR REMOVED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE NINETY THREE. I SEE NO
ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM. WILL
TO REMOTE VIDEO STATE. OUR TV
IS BLANK I SEE NO ONE- WHEN
THIS IS ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE NINETY
THREE OPERATOR. IF IN
OPPOSITION AB TWELVE NINETY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU- MOVING BACK TO MR
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE FIRST OF ALL. KITCO
OTHER VEHICLE AUTHOR ON YOUR
BILL. THEY'RE GONNA TALK TO
JUDGES ABOUT THIS AT LENGTH SO
CAN YOU BRING IT FORWARD- WITH
THE TO CLOSE MISTER COOLEY
ACROSS HER AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
I BELIEVE HIS OF THE MOTION. I
THINK I MADE THE MOTION RIGHT.
OKAY MOTION BY CERVANTES SECOND
BY WELL DAHLE L. SECRETARY WE
CALL ROLE PLEASE THE MOTION IS
DEPRESSING BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL
RIGHT VOEPEL I CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY HI COOLEY
I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL ICE THEY
ARE TO. FIFTY SIX BOTH CAN
MISTER COOL YOUR BILLS ON CALL
I HAVE SOME BILLS ARE UP SOME
OF THE GO BE A WITNESS AND THAT
THE VICE CHAIR MISTER VOEPEL IS
GONNA. TAKE OVER.
FIRST BILL
MISTER CHAIR COOPER IS ITEM
FOURTEEN A. B. THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE PROCEED. I'LL MAKE THIS
BRIEF MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST A.
B. THIRTY SIXTEEN WILL HELP
CLOSE THE GENDER AND ETHNICITY
PAY GAP WITH THE UNDER
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES IN STATE CIVIL
SERVICE CLASSIFICATIONS. AB
THREE ONE SIX REQUIRE STATE
AGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO PAY A
DETAILED REPORT ON GENDER AND
ETHNICITY WAGE DISPARITY IN THE
UNDER REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN
AND MINORITIES. THE. VERY WELL
I BELIEVE WE HAVE NO WITNESSES
ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL. ARE
THERE ANY I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
IN THE HEARING ROOM. AND FOR
VIDEO STATIONS THE SCREEN IS
BLANK. OPERATOR PLEASE GO FOR
ANY COLOR IN SUPPORT. ANY COLOR
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN JUST ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE SOMEBODY QUEUING UP. HI
THIS IS BETH. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HI THIS IS BETH CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. OKAY THANK YOU WHEN THEY
ANNOUNCE YOUR NUMBER IT WILL BE
THREE SIX THANKS I THANK YOU
BACK INTO THE CALL NOW THREE
SIX SIX AND YOU SHOULD BE THE
FIRST ONE UP ONE MOMENT. THREE
THIS IS AB THREE ONE SIX. JUST
DON'T HEAR. WE HAVE ONE THREE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CORCUERA WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE
ONE SIX. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
ISSUE THIS TIME. THANK YOU. I
DON'T SEE ANY JANA ONE IN THE
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION. I'M
LOOKING AT THE VIDEO SCREEN I
SEE NO ONE FOR OPPOSITION
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY PHONE
PEOPLE FOR OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE ONE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THE. AND NO ONE IS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. VERY WELL I BELIEVE
I HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AND A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOLD RUN.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE.
VERY WELL PLEASE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION AS THE PASS AND
THE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI
COOPER AYE VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL
AYE CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL PUT ON
ALL I SEE ARE TO. VETR. SIX
ZERO. PLEASE THAT MILAN KALRA
WELL. AND IT'S UP FOR CALL.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM FIFTEEN
AB THREE EIGHTY SIX MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MR AB THREE
SIX IS INTENDED TO GIVE OUR
PUBLIC PENSIONS THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE TO
INVESTIMENTOS CALIFORNIA'S
PENSION FUNDS. THE BILL CREATED
PUBLIC RECORDS DISCLOSURE
STRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS PUBLIC
PENSION SYSTEMS LIKE CALPERS TO
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE INVESTMENTS
IN THE PRIVATE LOW MARKET. THE
SAME WAY YOUR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION IS ALL CONFIDENTIAL
BY YOUR MORTGAGE COMPANY THIS
BILL SOUTH BAY STRUCTURE TO
PROTECT THE BORROWER'S
INFORMATION FOR PEGASYSTEMS
CAPITAL THREE PRIVATE LOANS.
WITH ME TODAY TESTIFYING AS THE
DENTAL BROWN CALPERS
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIVISION
CHIEF WHO IS THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. I BELIEVE THIS IS BY
PHONE OPERATOR. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
DANNY BROWN ON BEHALF CALPERS
BOARD OF ADMINISTRATION
SPONSORED THE BILL. I'LL KEEP
MY COMMENTS SHORT BUT FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE IN THE WORK BY THE
CANADIAN REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
STAFF. AB THREE EIGHTY SIX
CREATES A DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE
GROUP BRINGING THE MANAGEMENT
OF PRIVATE DEBT INVESTMENTS IN
HOUSE. WHICH WOULD AMONG OTHER
THINGS PROVIDE THE CALPERS
BOARD AND INVESTMENT STAFF MORE
DIRECT CONTROL OF THE
INVESTMENTS AND APPOINTS
MANAGING EACH PAY TO EXTERNAL
INVESTMENT MANAGERS. OF THIS
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE IS
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAW
RELATED TO PUBLIC RECORDS. ON
CALPERS DOES ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LEGITIMATE INTERESTS OF THE
PUBLIC IN KNOWING HOW PUBLIC
MONIES ARE INVESTED THE SMALL
THE OBLIGATION TO BE RESPONSIVE.
TO THE INFORMATION REQUEST.
HOUSE DISCLOSURE THE BALLOT.
MARC EXPECT. WITH THE NEED FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN CALPERS
INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS IMPORTANT YOUR-
THANK OU. I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. OPERATOR.
HELLO. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DAVID SORENSEN A CALPERS
BENEFICIARIES RETIRED AFTER
SERVING PRISON TWO YEARS AS
PROSECUTOR AND SILICON VALLEY.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA. AMANDA
THE CALPERS LONG TRUST ASSETS
TO ACCOMPANY BALLPOINT JACK.
COULD REFUSE TO DISCLOSE UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT THE PUMP JACK IS OWNED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. AS WELL AS THE
TERMS AND THE COLLATERAL ABOUT
WON'T. THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. FINANCIAL
POSITION RIGHT REPORTS OF
SHARKS PLAYERS FROM WALL STREET
USING THESE PROPOSED PRIVATE
LOANS TO PAY THEMSELVES HUGE
DIVIDENDS BY LOADING THEIR
PORTFOLIO COMPANIES UP WITH
THAT BUT THE CONSTITUENT OWNERS
AREN'T RESPONSIBLE HEY. PRIVATE
MINING IS SUCH A GREAT
INVESTMENT WHY ARE CAL STUDENTS
THEN THE CERTAIN THIRTY SEVEN
AT COUNTIES ON THIS BILL. THIS
VERY BILL HAD TO BE PULLED IN
THE LAST SESSION WHEN THE CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER CALPERS
SUDDENLY RESIGNED AFTER IT WAS
EXPOSED THAT HE HAD EXTENSIVE
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
INVOLVING SOME OF THE SAME WALL
STREET PLAYERS. THE CEO AND
BOARD PRESIDENT THAT IS NEEDED
IN THE PERHAPS THE DAY AND TO
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND NOT
DEMANDED THE BEST MEMBERS
REQUIRED BY THE CREATIVELY
FORMAT. BUT INSTEAD COVERED UP
THE CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICERS
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST FROM THE
OTHER BOARD MEMBERS THE F. PPC
AND THE PUBLIC FOR NEARLY TWO
YEARS. SADLY GREATER
TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED TO
CALPERS NOT MUCH. CALPERS HAS
REJECTED OR PDAS PROPOSAL OF
AMENDMENTS TO CORRECT THE
DEFICIENCIES IN THIS BILL WELL
PROTECTING LEGITIMATE. BAR WILL
PRIVACY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS A
TERROR YEAR FOR US TO HELP THE
THESE TALK TO. IN PUBLIC. I
RESPECTFULLY READ. THAT THE
ECONOMY MEMBERS TO ADVANCE THIS
OVERBROAD BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I SEE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
VIDEO SCREEN IS BLANK FOR
SUPPORT. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT OF. THREE
EIGHTY SIX WHICH WAS ONE OF
THEIR AT THIS TIME. HAVE NOTING
TO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE I SEE NO ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON VIDEO NO WE
DO NOT OPERATOR OTHER ANY.
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION. TO THREE
EIGHTY SIX. IF YOU'RE NOT
LISTEN TO THREE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS VERY WELL IS RAPPER
UP SIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. MADAM CLERK
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE. O THE
MOTION- RIGHT. HE IS TO COOLEY
MADE MOTION AND MISTER
O'DONNELL SECOND. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY COOPER
HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL HI VOEPEL
I CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I SAY ARE TO.
PROMOTER SIX ZERO BUT THE BILL
ON CALL. BILLS LOCAL. THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM SIXTEEN A. B.
TEND THIRTY TWO SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES THE
US MILITARY RESERVE AND
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD
SERVICE MEMBERS WHO WORK FOR
THE STATE CAN BE AND HAVE BEEN
ACTIVATED FOR MILITARY SERVICE
IN TIMES OF CRISIS THIS IS BEEN
DUPLICATED COVERT THESE MEN AND
WOMEN HAVE BEEN OPERATING UNDER
PRESIDENTIAL DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY LET'S ACTIVATE THESE MEN
AND WOMEN CAN ONLY BE
COMPENSATED FOR THE AMOUNT
AUTHORIZED BY THE NATIONAL
GUARD AND NOT BY THEIR
EMPLOYER. BY LAW THE SERVICE
WOMEN AND MEN OUR SCHOOLS BE
MADE WHOLE BY THE COMPENSATION
PEOPLE THEIR CIVILIAN
EMPLOYMENT THIS WAS NOT HOW IT
TRANSPIRED IN THE PANDEMIC OF
COVERT- OF LACK OF CLARITY IN
EXISTING LAW. MANY OF OUR
SERVICE WOMEN IN MEN'S PAY WAS
DELAYED IN SOME CASES UP TO
ALMOST A YEAR. IT IS
UNTHINKABLE THAT WE CALL THESE
FIVE PEOPLE TO SERVICE.
PLACEMENT HARM'S WAY IN THE
SAME TIME CREATE A FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FOR THEM THEIR
FAMILIES. AB TEN THIRTY TWO
WILL GIVE CLEAR DIRECTION TO
MEET THE INTENT OF THE LAW AND
MAKE THOSE WHO WE ALL CALL IN
THE HIGHER SERVICE HOLE. SO
WHEN THEY'RE SERVING THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT MEETING
THEIR PERSONAL FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS. WITH ME IS MATTHEW
EASLEY CHIEF LOBBYIST THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. SPONSOR.
OPERATOR. THANK YOU THIS IS
MATTHEW COOLEY THE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION HERE
SPEAKING SUPPORT STAFF AT THE
SPONSOR OF AB TEN THIRTY TWO.
THIS BILL ENSURES STATE
EMPLOYEES CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COUNTRY AND TIME OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY FOR UP TO
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS
INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAY LIMIT AND PROVIDE
CLARITY DELIMITING DELAY THE
PAYMENT. MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY RESERVE AND NATIONAL
GUARD OFTEN MAKE SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS MONEY WHILE ON MILITARY
ORDERS THAN THEY DO IN THEIR
CIVILIAN EMPLOYMENT. THE
VARIOUS CATEGORIES OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR DIFFERENTIAL
PAY PROVIDE FINANCIAL SECURITY
TO STATE EMPLOYEES TO ENSURE
THAT UNDER CERTAIN. UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES THEY ARE
PAID LESS WHILE SERVING OUR
COUNTRY. THE CONFLICTING
INTERPRETATIONS OF REFERENCE
THE TITLE CAME TO THE US CODE
AT THE THIRTY FOR ACTIVATION
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF PDP AWAY.
AND OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE WERE DELAYED
PAYMENTS GUARANTEED IN STATE
LAW FOR OVER TEN MONTHS. IN
ADDITION TO THE SAID
TECHNICALLY GET DELAYING
PAYMENT CURRENT STATUTE DOES
NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH ELIGIBILITY
TO SUFFICIENTLY COVER THE
NECESSARY TIME FRAMES. FOR
WHICH SOME STATE WORKERS ARE
BEING ACTIVATED. AT THE TIME
THAT THAT YOU WOULD RETURN THE
LEGISLATURE HAD PROBABLY NOT
ANTICIPATED THE WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC. THAT WOULD BRING THE
COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA TO A
STANDSTILL FOR OVER A YEAR.
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING. EXISTING HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS OF ELIGIBILITY HAS
TURNED OUT TO BE WHOLLY
INSUFFICIENT. ALMOST EMPLOYEES
ACTIVATED FOR COVERED RESPONSE
WERE ACTIVATED FOR UNDER UNDER
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. A
HANDFUL OF THE STATE EMPLOYEES
HAVE BEEN ACTIVATED FOR WELL
BEYOND A HUNDRED EIGHTY DILLON
AT. AND IN THE PROCESS THEY'VE-
HAD TO ABSORB SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL IMPACT BECAUSE THEY
MAKE CONSIDERABLY LESS WHILE
SERVING IN THE MILITARY. AB TEN
THIRTY TO THE IMPORTANT STEPS
TO SAFEGUARD FINANCIAL SECURITY
OF CAIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES. WERE CALLED SERVING
RESPONSE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
LIKE THAT THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL FOR IT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. VERY WELL I SEE
NO. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
SEE. NO BODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THE VIDEO MONITOR FOR
THOSE AND SUPPORT IS EMPTY
OPERATOR PLEASE EE WHO'S ON
THE PHONE LINE FOR A. B. TEN
THIRTY TWO. IN ORDER SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF TEN THIRTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO.
MISTER KNOWN HAS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. VERY WELL. ONCE
AGAIN. ZERO OPPOSITION IN ROOM.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WHO MOVED. I HOPE. DOES IT GO
TOO FAST FOR ME. THE MOVE TOO
FAST. THE SERVER. DO WE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. FROM
THE COMMITTEE. VERY WELL WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- DONALD AND ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CERVANTES. CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CABALLERO
CALDERON I'M SORRY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS IN BEAVER REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERAN AFFAIRS COOPER HI
COOPER AYE VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL I
CALDERON CALDERON AYE CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY COOLEY AYE
O'DONNELL AYE PATERNAL AYE C.
R. TO. THE ROOTS HAS SIX ZERO
WE'RE GONNA PUT IT ON CALL.
VERY WELL THE BILL IS ON CALL.
IT BRINGS US TO NUMBER
SEVENTEEN ACR FORTY FIVE. THERE
IS A SIGNATURE MEMBERS THE
MERIT AWARD PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN FIFTY
AS AN INCENTIVE AWARDS SYSTEM
TO RECOGNIZE EMPLOYEES
CONTRIBUTIONS TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AND ITS OPERATIONS.
OR BOARD AND KELLY CHART
APPROVED A CASH AWARD IN EXCESS
OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS-
TOWARDS IN EXCESS OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THE DEPARTMENT AVAILABLE
SERVICES PAID INITIAL FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
REMAINING BALANCE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY DOLLARS REQUIRES
A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. ACR
FORTY FIVE AUTHORIZES AN AWARD
PAYMENT OF SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS FOR EMPLOYEE SUGGESTION
THAT LED TO SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE BOTH. WELL. VERY WELL. I
SEE NO WITNESSES. I SEE NO ONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT.
I SEE NO ONE ON THE VIDEO
STATION IN SUPPORT OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. FOR MR
WE HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. VERY WELL. WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM. DO NOT
APPEAR TO BE HERE FOR
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE VIDEO
STATIONS OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. IF IN OPPOSITION
ACR FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME VERY WELL. COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. VERY
WELL I HAVE A MOTION FROM MR
COOLEY AND A SECOND FROM
MISTRAL DONALD I HOPE I GOT
THAT ONE RIGHT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI
COOPER HI VOEPEL HI VOEPEL I
CALDERON CALDERON CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I COOLEY. COOLEY I
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I SEE ARE
TO. FOR INVESTED ZERO FOR THE
BILL AND CALL BILLS LOCAL. THE
BRIDGE IS THE ITEM EIGHTEEN A.
J. R. NINE SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUE THIS IS OUR LAST ITEM
AND I KNOW YOU'RE VERY EXCITED
AS A AS A LOT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE. VERY WELL. I
SEE NO WITNESSES. OH NO WE DO
HAVE WITNESSES. THANK. ALSO
MAKE A BRIEF STATEMENT MISTER
MISTER CHAIR AJ ARE NINE OR
JUST CONGRESS TO REPEAL THE
GOVERNMENT PENSION OFFSET IN
THE WINDFALL ELIMINATION
PROVISION FROM SOCIAL SECURITY
ACT MANY OF CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
UNFAIRLY PENALIZED BY SOCIAL
SECURITY OFFSETS THE REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE THEIR OWN SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS THE TEACHERS
BENEFITS ORDER SPOUSAL BENEFITS
THANK YOU VERY WELL YOU HAVE NO
OTHER WITNESSES. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE TO ON THE PHONE. OPERATOR
PLEASE. WHAT IS YOUR ONE ARE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JENNIFER BAKER AGAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SPONSORED A CHAIR
NINE ON THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION CALLED UPON CONGRESS
TO PASS AND THE PRESIDENT TO
FIND A REPEAL OF THE WINDFALL
ELIMINATION PROVISION AND THE
GOVERNMENT PENSION OFFSET. 72%
OF CHARACTERS MEMBERS ARE WOMEN
THESE UNFAIR SOCIAL SECURITY
OFFSETS HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT DECADES
RECRUITING INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTICULARLY IN
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATH TO BECOME A SECOND
CAREER TEACHER. UNFORTUNATELY
SO MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOW FINDING THAT THEY'RE
BEING PENALIZED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVELIF YOUR CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN. AT THE BOAT BABY
BOOMER GENERATION INCREASING
RETIREMENT THIS GENERATION IS
BECOMING THE FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION WHICH WILL
EXACERBATE THE SITUATION AS WE
SEE MORE TEACHERS IN TRAINING
AFTER THE RETIREMENT YEAR.
EIGHT YEAR NINE WILL ASSIST IN
AFFECTING THE NECESSARY CHANGES
WE NEED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
REMEDY THIS UNFAIR PENALTY ON
CALIFORNIA'S RETIRED MEN AND
CAL ARCHIE EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
RETIRED TEACHERS. AND ASK. FOR
YOUR SUPPORT A. B. J. R. NINE.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BROUGH SPEAKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
URGING CONGRESS TO REPEAL WITH
GPO FROM THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ACT IS OUTDATED POLICIES ARE
HARMING OUR MEMBERS IN OUR
PROFESSION DOES BEHIND THEM THE
TERM IN INCOME THEY HAVE EARNED
THAT THEY HAVE PAID FOR. I WAS
THE FIFTH GRADE TEACHER IN SAN
JOSE DURING A TEACHER SHOWED
SIMILAR TO THE ONE THAT WE
CURRENTLY FACE WITH SO MANY
VACANCIES MANY OF THE TEACHERS
I WORKED WITH HAD LEFT SILICON
VALLEY TECH INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT FIND THEIR WORK
DISTILLING ONE HAD A LOCAL
WORKING WITH CHILDREN THAT HAVE
SPECIAL SKILLS THAT MADE OUR
LEARNING COMMUNITY ONE AMAZING
PLACE TO COME TO WORK EACH DAY
THESE TALENTED INDIVIDUALS CAME
INTO TEACHING WITH A SECOND
CAREER HAVING SPENT DECADES AT
PLACES LIKE INTEL OR ORACLE. I
HAD NEVER HEARD OF WITH GPO THE
TEACHER NEITHER HAVE DAY THEY
WERE UNAWARE THAT THE DECISION
THEIR DECISION TO BE A CHAMPION
FOR CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITIES
TO CHANGE CAREERS WAS A
DECISION THAT WOULD REDUCE THE
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS THEY
HAVE BEEN PAYING INTO ALL OF
THOSE YEARS IT'S WORSE THAN
WRONG AN INCREDIBLY UNFAIR WE
DO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
HIS. LEADERSHIP AND OTHER
SUPPORT. VERY WELL. WE HAVE NO
WITH THIS IT SHOULDN'T I SEEING
NO WITH IN HEARING ROOM IN. I
SEE NO WITNESSES ON THE SCREEN
ON THE VIDEO SCREEN IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE LINES. IN SUPPORT OF
A J. R. NINE. THE DIRECTORS TO
COME AND SUPPORT OF A DAY ARE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND TO GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN Q. THANK YOU SIR YES
HIS CHARGES WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL. AND I
HEAR A LOT OF FOLKS COME UP.
BEFORE THE MICROPHONE AND THEY
SAY WILL CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
DON'T PARTICIPATE SO THEY DON'T
GET SOCIAL SECURITY. BUT THE
ISSUE HERE IS THEY MIGHT HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN SOCIAL SECURITY
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND THEN
WHEN THEY GO TO RETIRE FIND OUT
THAT THEY CANNOT RECAPTURE-
WHAT THEY PUT IN. A TO THE
SOCIAL SECURITY SYSTEM SO
THERE'S REALLY AN UNFAIR THING
IF YOU WILL GOING ON HERE THAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS I
THINK THE AUTHOR. FOR THIS BILL.
VERY WELL I SEE NO ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE ON THE SCREEN IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO A J. R. NINE. I
DO WISH COMMON IN OPPOSITION OF
AJ ARE NINE IN A PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU. TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. C. NONE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER COOLEY AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON FINALLY GOT IT RIGHT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THIRD
READING COOPER HI COOPER I
VOEPEL HI VOEPEL AYE CALDERON
AYE CALDERON AYE CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE O'DONNELL AYE BUT ON ALL I
SEE ARE TO. SARATOGA MISTER
CHAIR THIS BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU. ABOUT THE- QUITE A
NUMBER OF BILLS ON CALL SO
MEDIC SECRETARY WOULD YOU GO
FEELS BILLS AND- CULTURAL
PLEASE. START WITH THE CONSENT
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THREE
ONE THREE ITEM NUMBER TWO A
BEFORE FOR ITEM NUMBER. THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE. CURRENT
LOTUS SIX ZERO TURNER I
CERVANTES. CERVANTES I. SEVEN
ZERO THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT IN
CALABASAS ON SEVEN ISRAEL VOTE
CLOSE THREE ITEMS. THANK YOU. I
DON'T MEMBER FOR CURRENT VOTERS.
FOR TWO ZERO A TEACHER WHO
VOTED I. CERVANTES CERVANTES I
SAY ARE TOO. HIGH THERE ARE TWO
I AND VOTE IS. SIX ZERO. THE
ADDAMS OUT. THE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. AB AND THAT PASSES THOSE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SAID. YES
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY TWO
THREE SEVEN SIX ZERO YES
CORRECT. THE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
CURRENT POTUS SIX ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING I SEE ARE TO NOW SAY ARE
TO NOTE. THAT VOTERS SIX ONE. I
AM FIVE PLUS A SIX TO ONE.
SEVEN WITHOUT THE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB FIVE FIVE ONE THE
CURRENT VOTERS FOR ONE CHURCH
VOTED I. O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
NOT VOTING SARATOGA NOW SEE OUR
TO KNOW. THAT VOTE IS FOR TWO
THAT BILL IS OUT NUMBER SIX
PASSES FOR TWO WITH IT FELT. I
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB SIX
FIFTEEN THE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE
ONE. CHERVONA I SEE OUR TELL
NOW C. R. TURNER. PRINT VOTERS
SIX ONE THAT BILL OUT A NUMBER
PATH SEVEN PASSED THE SIX TO
ONE. PEOPLE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB EIGHT FORTY FIVE. KERN VOTER
SIX ZERO. CHAIR VOTING I SAY
ARE TO KNOW. THEY ARE TO KNOW
THAT FOOD IS SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT NUMBER EIGHT PASSED
THE SEVEN SEVEN ZERO SEVEN FOUR
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
THAT SEVEN ONE SIX SIX ONE MY
EX ONE OKAY SIX ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY. CURRENT VOTERS
THREE ZERO. CHáVEZ AYE
CERVANTES. CERVANTES I DONAL
O'DONNELL I SEE ARE TWO NINE
ZERO TWO I. CURRENT VOTERS SIX
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT OF THE
NUMBER ONE PASSE THE SIX ZERO.
I'M SORRY STORY NUMBER NINE
HE'S MADE. ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TEN THIRTY ONE CURRENT VOTERS
FOR TWO ZERO. CHAIR VOTING HI
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE.
O'DONNELL SAY ARE TOO HIGH C.
R. TWO I. THE BILL HAS SIX
BOATS THAT BILL IS OUT. THAT
THAT WAS NUMBER TWO UNTEN
ANTENNAS THE SIX SIX ZERO YES
THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY NINE CURRENT
BOTH SIX ZERO CHAIR VOTING I
SAY ARE TO HIGH SIERRA TO OUR
THAT BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
ABILITY OUT A NUMBER GETS OUT A
NUMBER ELEVEN SEVEN ZERO. I AM
NUMBER TWELVE AB FIVE THIRTY
NINE PRINT VOTER SIX ZERO.
CHARITY I SEE ARE TOO HIGH
SIERRA TO OUR THAT BILL IS OUT
WITH SEVEN ZERO UNTIL WITHOUT.
SEVEN ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWELVE THIRTY
NINE CURRENT VOTER SIX ZERO
GERMANY I SEE ARE TOO HIGH. C.
R. TO BUY THAT BILL IS OUT ON
THE SEVEN ZERO VOTE ON THIRTEEN
IS OUT OF THE SEVEN ZERO VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE SIXTEEN CURRENT LOTUS SIX
ZERO SHARE VOTING I SEE ARE TO.
I SEE ARE TOO HIGH BILLS OUT
AND SEVEN ZERO UNDER FOURTEEN
TO SELL SEVEN ZERO. I ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN. EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX CURRENT VOTERS SIX
ZERO. CHAIR VOTING I SEE ARE
TELL. HI ZERO TWO I ABILITY OUT
ON THE SEVENTH YEAR VOTE UNDER
FIFTEEN DELTA SEVEN ZERO VOTE.
I NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TEN THIRTY
TWO CURRENT VENICE SIX ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING I SEE ARE TWO FIVE
ZERO TWO I THAT BILL WITHOUT ON
THE SEVEN ZERO VOTE OF FIFTEEN
DOLLARS SEVEN ZERO VOTE. I AND
NUMBER SEVENTEEN ACR FORTY
FIVE. KERN VOTERS SIX ZERO
CHAIR VOTING I SEE ARE TWO FIVE
ZERO TWO I THAT BILL IS OUT ON
THE SEVEN ZERO. ADAM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN DOT SEVEN ZERO VOTE I
AM NUMBER EIGHTEEN CURRENT VOTE
S. H. A. R. NINE CURRENT LOTUS
SIX ZERO CHAIR VOTING PRICING
ARE TELL. STATE I'M SORRY I'M
NOT VOTING C. R. TURNOUT
VOTING. THAT BILL IS OUT SIX
ZERO A NUMBER EIGHTEEN IS OUT
SIX ZERO- THAT BRINGS US TO THE
END OF OUR AGENDA- THANKS
NICHOLAS FOR BRING US OF THE
VERY LONG AGENDA THEY- THIS
MEANS THE GERMAN THANK YOU.